CNN has leaked audio of Donald Trump
confessing to his crime yeah not really
it's uh it's kind of nonsense audio and
a lot of people are like this is the big
breaking story about Trump the the audio
proves doesn't prove anything but we are
going to talk about that however we're
not leading with that story and I'm
gonna tell you why
and it matters
because for eight years the media has
lied about the context of every single
Story related to Donald Trump and so
when they come out CNN publishes audio
and they say this audio proves something
the rule is you're supposed to wait
three days because then invariably
something else comes out goes actually
that was fake and that seems to be the
way it goes so we'll definitely talk
about the the audio uh leaks of Donald
Trump's conversation pretend to classify
documents but we do have more pressing
and important news surrounding
censorship the culture war and a bunch
of other topics so it seems Bud likes
Bud Light sales have dropped to a new
record low and finally finally Bud Light
Anheuser bush has fired the marketing
team now I know a lot of people thought
that it already happened it did not they
put them on leave we thought this would
blow over and they'd bring these people
back while surprise surprise the boycott
is holding sales are dropping and they
finally said you fired so we'll talk
about that
we're gonna talk about we got some other
news Target is getting heat once again
uh a producer from Tucker Carlson is
coming out slamming the network because
they just nuked the remaining producers
from Tucker Carlson I want to talk about
that and then uh the quarter we had a
big announcement he is I want to be
careful how I phrase this sort of
leaving YouTube making YouTube a back
burner and this is a big shift because
we're seeing something similar with Tim
Dillon large prominent influential
personalities in the political and
cultural space all around the same time
are announcing that they're moving to
rumble and they're getting off YouTube
this Market competition as it works so
we'll talk about that but before we get
started my friends head over to
castbrew.com the official sponsor of
timcast IRL in fact we're sponsoring
ourselves because we own cast Brew if
you want to help fight the commies you
buy coffee from us and it actually is
some of the best coffee I have to be
honest and I mean this sincerely we
worked really hard to make good coffee
and I believe Appalachian nights is the
best coffee I've ever had I'm not
kidding and Roberto Jr second best
coffee for a while I thought I Rise with
Roberto Jr uh blend was the best and
then I started drinking the dark roast
Appalachian nights and I went right back
to the dark roast I really do think so
and um to be honest it's not hard for me
to say I think it's the best I actually
worked on the blend found what I thought
was the best blend and then we made it
and I think it's fantastic so if you
want to support the show and you like a
good cup of coffee go to castbrew.com
buy your coffee today join the cast Brew
Coffee Club get three bags every month
K-Cups are coming new Blends we got
unwoke sleepy Joe decaf Blends are
coming a lot of a lot of great stuff in
the works working on the coffee shop so
thank you all for your support and also
don't forget to go to timcast.com click
join us become a member to support us
directly and you will get access to
uncensored members only after shows
Monday through Thursday where as a
member you can actually submit questions
and call into the show to talk to us and
our guests totally worth it and we do
appreciate your support so smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the share with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and so much more is Gene Hamilton hello
how are y'all who are you what do you do
I am a vice president general counsel of
America First legal and uh we we're here
to fight for the common person for the
American for True traditional American
values so we represent clients in court
we do all kinds of things to oversight
public attention uh to things government
overreach excesses private corporations
the like pushing back on wokeness
all all of the stuff that we're seeing
all over the place we want to be right
in and we're doing our best right now to
get on there's there is big news coming
this week you were mentioning with the
Supreme Court and affirmative action so
that'll be really interesting to see
maybe we'll get into that later in the
show sounds great thanks for hanging out
man should be fun we got
I have a YouTube channel called
Freedom Tunes where we make animated
cartoons we release the video last week
where I reviewed and fixed a bunch of
left-wing memes they were broken I had
to make them funny and I did so if you
guys want to check that out I think
you'll enjoy it we also have a 30 minute
long version of that same video an
Extended Cut behind the paywall at
freedomtunes.com if you guys want to go
over there check that out become members
you'll be able to see it and uh I think
I think those are your best the meme
reviews the meme reviews one thank you
yeah they're a lot of fun the the the
conspiracy pyramid was one of the best
thank you well we do where do you see
the pride me a lot of people were saying
the pride one was the best so I want to
encourage you you got to watch that one
everyone you have to watch it you went
you went home if you love me and want to
support my work I want to watch it hey
guys Ian Crossland Ian crossland.net
happy to be here follow me anywhere on
the internet at Ian Crossland if you
like me
uh and I'll see you later
and I'm search.com I'm ready to start
when you guys are here's the big news
and the big news is not that they're
leaked audio of Donald Trump because
it's been eight years of that I'm so
bored with it now the big news is from
The Daily Caller top Anheuser-Busch
Marketing Executives behind boycott are
no longer employed the top two
Anheuser-Busch Marketing Executives were
placed on leave amid the company shakeup
no longer work for the brand a source
inside and azerbush confirmed in texts
obtained by The Daily Caller on Tuesday
group vice president for marketing
Daniel Blake and Bud Light marketing
vice president Alyssa heinershide are
gone gone according to obtained text
messages with a current Regional head of
marketing the caller is granting
anonymity to the source to discuss
lengthy fraught internal company policy
quote to my understanding if we publicly
announce the word fire it opens up the
potential for them to sue us that's why
we said leave of absence the source that
in text message obtained by the caller
the wholesalers would have had an
absolute Heyday with leadership if they
didn't remove her the source inside the
company also said to be fair Daniel
Blake was really awesome I think he was
just caught in the crossfire but also he
did hire her so that's a fault
wholesalers were told they are both gone
for good by leadership during in-person
conversations they already shifted all
their direct reports to new people and
the head of marketing The Source added
another text message obtained by the
caller I'll tell you why this is
important
what we thought was going to happen
there's a hubbub some Bubble Up In The
Press after a couple days or a week
sales return to normal the boycott
falters they announced they're coming
back from their leave of evidence or or
just don't announce anything and they
just slide back in their positions and
everything resumes and they keep on
keeping on but that's not what happened
what happened so far is that three
months on Bud Light sales continue to
get worse and now they've officially
terminated these individuals Starbucks
just had a strike last week because
they're telling people to take down
Pride decorations targets stock value is
collapsing and a bunch of other brands
are reeling because ladies and gentlemen
get what go broke is becoming more and
more powerful
yeah absolutely you'd love to see it I
had a similar expectation when this all
began I thought you know people are
going to stop drinking bud light for a
little while but they're gonna they're
gonna go back to it I I think that when
conservatives have tried boycotts in the
past they haven't really stuck to them
and of course this situation is a little
bit different and one key detail I was
missing is that you don't have to be a
conservative to be disgusted by this
kind of thing there's a large subsection
in this country which still finds a man
in a dress to be very off-putting and so
even without having any kind of
organization or political ideology
behind it people said I'm not drinking
that anymore I just I I disagree a
little bit I think the average person
does not care about a man in a dress and
that's why it was tolerated for so long
what they care about is one it was
marketing beer to kids and two we're
seeing more and more of the grooming
stuff parents started seeing books in
schools that were teaching children
about adult explicit content and now
what's happening is it's causing a
backlash that's encompassing more than
just the core issue right so when a
parent sees a book like this book is gay
which which Ian purchased and it taught
it teaches children how to use adult sex
apps there's a backlash and everything
it's it's collateral damage so for a
long time you get a guy in a dress what
happens the average default Urban
liberal or Suburban liberal or whatever
type didn't care and I said I don't care
what these people are doing in their in
their own homes they're liberals right
so they're like do whatever you want
live and live then these books come out
come in these schools now they see it
and they associate all of it with each
other
that's why now in Bud Light it's not
just this even Bud Light sponsoring
Toronto Pride where you've got naked men
you know gyrating in front of children
so people see that and they're just like
all of it gone don't want it no sorry
bye-bye I I agree with you that the
grooming and all of the perversity
that's come into the Limelight in a way
that it wasn't before is also factoring
into people's decision to boycott but I
would say that people have traditionally
and historically still been off put by
seeing a man in a dress I would say that
that was the case
um all the way up until now no right
right right like
and Brands weren't using them as mascots
I was looking at old photos from
Atlantic City in the 20s and people are
out in summer wearing suits yeah like it
was like yes people were offended by
people who didn't wear the uniform so
like even up for for a long period of
time we got to a point where a guy in
drag a person a cross-dresser male or
female or whatever was for for a long
time socially completely unacceptable
but with the liberal period in the past
20 or so years they said ah you live in
the live do do your thing I don't care
but what I'm saying now is yes people
may not like it but they tolerate it and
said we don't care we tolerate this now
they're not tolering it at all yeah no
no I agree I guess my main point is just
that through that period where people
were tolerating it it wasn't because
they didn't find it off-putting they
were just willing to allow it to happen
somewhere else right right right right
yeah and now that it's affecting them
the pendulum is starting to stay in the
other direction yeah
so then what's the end result are we
gonna see
more Brands back off did we win is this
is this the the get well go broke is the
the the Brick that got pulled from the
tower that causes the total collapse
look I I mean I personally think it's
gonna depend on the brand unfortunately
I mean I think that there's if Ben and
Jerry's put Dylan Mulvaney on a carton
of ice cream it people wouldn't bat an
eye I mean because that's their customer
base right I don't agree I I just I just
don't know uh because that's that that's
how far out they are for Bud Light
and for most mainstream corporate
mainstream corporations families
especially touching on exactly the issue
that you just mentioned which is people
don't want this stuff shoved in their
face they don't they're tired of it and
so like for 20 years people tolerated
RuPaul's drag shows and all this other
stuff okay well yeah they're off doing
their own thing in their own life and
and but now they're they're doing
exactly what's happening but I think
like I I just with a bit with a brand
that is extremely liberal like Ben and
Jerry's I don't know with everything
else I think not on Ben and Jerry's Ben
and Jerry's a gas station brand yeah Ben
Jerry's is like Bud Light sure they do
kooky things you know like resist or
whatever but no one cares when they walk
in to grab a pint of ice cream they want
cookie dough and brownies that's all
they care about so when Bud Light became
political
in this particular way people were just
like nope not buying it and I think it's
because it's now affecting them Ben and
Jerry's does a lot of political stuff
but let's be real a guy walking into a
gas station for some cookie dough ice
cream doesn't care if it's if it's
Haagen-Dazs or Ben and Jerry's maybe he
likes Ben and Jerry's because it got
bigger cookie dough chunks that's about
it so if they started I I do think of
Ben and Jerry's put Dylan Mulvaney on
the carton it would sell a lot less I I
agree I agree this just crossed my mom
but I think a big mistake that Bud Light
made Anheuser-Busch is Dylan's not
really I mean I'm not going to claim if
he's trans or not but he's a he's an
actor and and he's doing Camp he's very
he's spoken outward that he's like
making fun of the whole process so it's
not like a real trans woman that's like
look we're identifying gender dysphoria
this person is like we're in support of
this community it's Dylan Mulvaney he's
a crazy actor he's like so they they
almost yeah mocked trans rights and
transgenderism by using Dylan as their
spokes model well this is the crazy
thing to me I think I think Dylan's
intention is to insult trans people
I I say it all the time I don't know how
you get anything else from that there
was like the recent video where Dylan is
on the red carpet and Tony the Tiger
comes out and Dylan starts panicking and
freaking out I'm like could you imagine
if if a white man like put on blackface
and went around and started hooting and
hot like Dylan Mulvaney
is is a comedian and actor who has has
done a bunch of ridiculous things like
The Price is Right video running around
and and rolling around on the ground
it's all it's it's like shock jock Borat
level stuff for real and so I I you you
look at these videos that Dylan's
produced come on let's be real Dylan's
singing about having a bulge is just to
insult trans people I and and you know
we had that uh that left his guest on
Friday Phil Labonte the other night was
saying her whole thing was literally
just whatever Tim says we're gonna agree
we're gonna say the opposite and that's
what ends up happening delmo then he
comes out puts on this performance
that's insulting and demeaning to women
and trans people we criticize Dylan for
doing it so they defend Dylan
interesting yeah I mean we're I I don't
make the same distinction that you guys
do I I view all of this the same way but
I'm curious about how the transgender
Community or people who identify as
transgender have responded to Dylan
prior to the public backlash well look
you have there are prominent uh
personalities who are trans who speak
out against these people yeah and there
is among transgender people there's a
left and a right as well so it's it's I
don't think you can you can you can hit
it all with one broad brush stroke you
know what I mean clearly is a unique
character that is is putting out a
performance and has even said this Dylan
Mulvaney did not come out and said they
weren't trans but did say they wanted to
move Beyond being identified as a trans
person something something that effect
for sure no I I don't disagree with you
guys at all that Dylan is a particularly
obnoxious example and I I don't disagree
that people who identify as trans have a
wide variety of political views where
I'm saying I don't draw the distinctions
I think all of it's insulting to women I
think all of it is a caricature of
Womanhood oh yeah no I'm saying that
Dylan's insulting trans people on top of
it like you know you can you can take a
look at um many look I'll I'll shout out
Blair white and I'll shout out Contra
points a a a I guess Blair is considered
conservative I don't know where where
Blair stands and Contra points is
considered liberal they're both serious
people you can disagree with them you
can you can uh have arguments around
their ideologies or the way they live
their lives but they're both serious
people who present arguments Dylan
Mulvaney puts high heels on in the woods
runs around and then sings about having
a bulge which just demeans and insults
trans people
like I just it's Borat so that makes me
think that maybe Gene you were onto
something that if if companies were to
go with you know utilizing
transgenderism as a marketing tactic but
not going for the campy clownish uh
people as their as their spokespeople
and they actually find like genuinely
you know trans people that are like
maybe they've been suffering or whatever
and they want to elevate that Community
somehow I could see that actually not
destroying a company maybe actually
helping I mean I just go back to the
RuPaul RuPaul has a show on what e or
whatever and how to show for decades
RuPaul's Drag Race show and all these
other things and and so you have you
have these examples of this stuff
happening where you have a base that is
conditioned in acculturated to this
lifestyle into this this stuff which
which with none of it I I agree with to
be clear
um quite the opposite but when you take
a brand like Bud Light yeah or you take
something like anything I mean take a
Ford Mustang if they if Ford decided
we're going to advertise their new
Mustang with with Dylan Mulvaney didn't
they did Ford do an advertisement with
Dylan no no they did they did a pride
rate who did the prize
somebody did do I I think someone might
have done a rainbow truck but also to be
clear there's something about the
rainbow that puts a layer of abstraction
over it I I don't think there was an
actual picture of somebody like Dylan
Mulvaney associated with it yeah in
2022.4 did it wow well let's let's jump
we got an update too check this out it's
from the New York Post Bud Light sales
reach new weekly low following Dylan
Mulvaney Fiasco sales of Bud Light
suffered their steepest weekly drop I
want to stress this all for you please
listen it has been three months
it's three months later and the worst
week so far
28.5 drop
it's getting worse
yo it's supposed to be easing up three
months on I think this is brand death I
think you know the way I described it
earlier is that maybe this is where we
wrap a nice little bow around the Bud
Light story Dylan Mulvaney destroyed
Anheuser-Busch
that's wild hey look the the company
exists they'll make money and I'm not
saying that they just disappear off the
face of the Earth but I wonder if we
might see a Cascade effect that I talked
about before
three months on and sales are still
getting worse that's crazy and now
they're talking about so they're doing
another free beer giveaway
then Memorial Day now it's the fourth of
July coming up Bud Light is giving away
their beer for free now that's the get
well go broke man right understatement
yeah no I I think I think that's very
accurate and this entire past pride
month seems to have been a complete
disaster for the left which I've I very
much enjoyed part of why I think this
was such a massive and strategic error
for Bud Light is because not only were
they not selling a particularly
impressive product people aren't buying
Bud Light out of a sense of brand
loyalty people aren't buying Bud Light
because it's the best of the best people
are buying Bud Light because it's
inexpensive and it's what they have
access to but they also have access to
many other beer brands nobody who's
drinking Bud Light is picky about the
beer they're drinking right they could
have a product that's not from
Anheuser-Busch and enjoy it just as much
if not more so what they did is they
tried to force something incredibly
controversial onto people with a brand
that those people didn't need and had
very easily accessible alternatives to
yeah 30 or 40 years ago go beer was like
you didn't have that many choices right
there were a lot of it was centralized
then all of a sudden microbrews got
super popular and now you've got like 6
000 different choices you can stock your
bar with I mean yeah why would you ever
go for trash like take a look at this
from the USA Today it's bland Bud Light
offers 15 beer rebates for Fourth of
July weekend amid boycott declining
sales I chose as neutral of a source as
I can they mentioned that 15 packs of
the beer sell for less than fifteen
dollars it's not that they're
practically free they're giving you
money so they mention that some of these
15 packs are 12.99 in this article and
that you get a 15 rebate ladies and
gentlemen this is a beer company that's
giving away its beer for free when I
when I see that I'm looking at the stock
right look at this
Anheuser-Busch and web in them in the
past six months is down 5.72 in the past
month they've actually recovered 3.8
percent yo the market often illogical a
beer company that doesn't sell beer it
gives it away for free that's something
people apparently have decided they
should invest in well and so this is
something maybe some people are just
trying to buy the dip they think it's
going to get better I can't imagine
anything else explaining that but I
think that there's something very
massive and catastrophic about this and
I mean catastrophic for them everyone's
been saying this is the best example of
a conservative boycott I've ever seen
this is one of the best examples of a
boycott in general I've ever seen when
was the last time you saw a brand that
was so heavily boycotted they started
giving their product away for free I've
never seen that happen before can you
guys think of any examples no of a
business that was losing customers at
such a rate that they started giving
their product away for free and people
still weren't taking it I've never seen
that happen before hey look their stock
has rebounded a couple of points in the
past week or so so that could be an
example of the people that sold so I'm
looking less for in May it dropped 20
percent they went from like 68 bucks to
52 or something like that and uh what
happened was a bunch of people probably
sold then the rest of the the world was
like uh oh and then they sold it dropped
so low then those original people that
sold bought back so yeah so they made
some money and they still have the same
amount of stock but then it dropped
again uh you know obviously people don't
want this stuff that's what I'm saying I
think maybe some people are trying to
buy the dip because they're thinking
this can't go on much longer yeah it's
not retail investment I guess probably
firms and they're doing analysis and
they're like okay we've seen it
stabilize it's been three months you
know we'll buy now and see what happens
people will get over it eventually you
know our stock price will go back up I
don't I don't know that they will I hope
they don't if I think they've really
done a number on themselves listen these
sale decline the sales decline at 20.5
percent
is with them offering these crazy
rebates right now you now they're
offering free beer they're like buy our
beer it's 12.99 for 15 pack you get a 15
rebate they call it practically free I'm
like yo they're giving you money they're
they're like okay up to 15 I think
they're covering the cost so it is just
free so they're giving their beer away
for free
they're trying to stem the bleed
if they don't do this it would be down
50 so they're hoping that when after
they're doing this because they know
Fourth of July weekend their sales are
going to be in the gutter they've got to
do something to keep the number up so
that after next week
we can see in an improvement well yeah
and I'll also say I think that bad
Fourth of July numbers are going to be
particularly abysmal that is really
going to hurt their market value if they
don't see any kind of bump for the
holiday oh that's true and but I mean I
think the other point here is that even
with
free beer
free beer Fourth of July weekend
if any of you all are going to barbecues
this weekend
who of you will be caught holding no a
Bud Light Trump I will make fun of
anyone who has it I will I will make fun
of anyone who who has it how about this
Shelby Talcott tweets Maga Mimosa the
featured drink at the NH Federation of
Republican women lilac luncheon where
Trump is scheduled to speak shortly and
there's uh Bud Light Budweiser and I
think is Stella is Stella man has her
friend I'm not sure I don't know but
they got Bud Light right there wouldn't
it be hysterical if Trump just started
trashing Bud Light while he was there
he's like I heard some people are saying
there was some Bud Light here like I
don't know quite frankly that would be
that would be the nail on the coffin we
went to an event in West Virginia I was
like a Republican's speech being given
and they had a a drink you know minibar
set up no Bud Light and I walked up and
I and the guy opened the fridge and I
could see Bud Light in the fridge and I
was like oh I see you got Bud Light down
there's like yeah we don't have it out
though because it's like they have the
stock if someone asks for it was out to
him but nobody's gonna buy it and I'm
like yeah okay so all the Anheuser Bush
product are pulled when we did our
events in in Texas we actually told the
bar no Anheuser-Busch products they
can't even do that at this Republican
event here's here's a question here's a
tough one for all of you
um
Trump is guaranteed to win in 2024 but
you have to drink a Bud Light okay don't
do it you throw that butt like back you
let people take a picture of you holding
a Bud Light Tim pool if it meant Trump
is guaranteed to win I here's the thing
sorry no no I don't think you would
because he wouldn't pardon you for it
he'd be like he'd be like Tim Drake that
Bud Light it was awful
I will
say well
don't say anything about how you would
drink Bud Light I will sacrifice for the
greater good of this country by drinking
it but like it means it guaranteed
Donald Trump the election yes Stella is
a b and Bev look at that Stella that's
him
I couldn't let you do it I said Tim no
there was there you know there have been
people who have been willing to
sacrifice everything to save everyone
Sheamus oh man look and you're saying
you if they said I was just asking you
quite frankly I want to see so hold on I
don't think Trump's gonna pardon you
they if they they come to you and say
Donald Trump okay time traveler comes
uh-huh and he says Sheamus you
understand the butterfly effect right
okay I'm telling you right now if you
let me take this picture of you drinking
a Bud Light Trump will get elected you
wouldn't do it I would not do evil that
good might come of it laughs
yeah I would drink the baby would you do
a keg stand if I like eggs and take it
off no Modelo that's fine though right I
don't know it's Modelo a b no but
seriously come on like I know it's
fantastic oh it's just good to know you
feel that way you know but I don't is
this like Trump sanctioned yeah modelo's
also AB in Bev no it's not the United
States it's constellation Brands oh fact
check we've got it on their website ab
and Bev Our Brands yeah outside of
outside of the United States so in the
U.S where sales are skyrocketing it's
owned by constellation Brands and
antitrust lawsuit we do not own this
delicious beer in the U.S that's a
disclaimer on their way wow it says that
it's interesting okay so did come on of
course everybody would if ever if if if
if there was some definitive proof the
Oracle of time the cia's time device you
could look into it and it was like if
everybody if all Trump supporters
started drinking Bud lightness yeah I
wouldn't trust it it's the same it's
like telling your device they're only
trying to get us to drink Bud Light to
boost their sales that's why they're
pulling this whole Trump supporters
discover an alien device that can show
them the future and they see a possible
future where if they all start drinking
Bud Light again Trump wins they would
dude Bud light's gonna sigh up us into
thinking that this is the truth
that's their marketing strand uh
strategy we we looked into the future
it's the only way the only way for Trump
to win oh my goodness actually to be
honest though I think it would be the
opposite I think if conservatives
actually gave in and did not boycott
these Brands without a doubt Trump would
lose the fact that we're seeing so many
regular people and conservatives
actually sustain a boycott yeah suggests
to me there will be the ground the
possible Ground Force for a trump
victory yeah well I think it's also just
indicative of the fact that your average
person isn't interested in having this
nonsense forced on them as we were
discussing earlier for a while people
were okay letting these things happen
far away from them where they wouldn't
have to see it but once you start
putting in their face they go you know
what if if it's either
um you stop doing this or it gets forced
on me I choose that you stop doing it
because I'm starting to feel like the
whole Live and Let Live thing was always
a lie let's talk about what's causing
this because
um Ian actually purchased this book
that's been the subject of great
controversy and I have this tweet it's
an I looked up on Amazon this book is
gay it's called an Ian has purchased it
right here on the back it says this book
is for underlined everyone regardless of
gender sexual preference this book is
for anyone who's ever dared to wonder
this book is for you they sell it to 14
to 17 year olds on Amazon Amazon says
reading age is 14 to 17 you can see here
at the bottom yet in the book it it
teaches you and explains how to use
adult sex apps yeah explicitly so this
is this is what happens
you have
for whatever reason people on the left
either because they're overt pedophiles
or because over tribalists will will
defend anything that the right opposes
you end up with a book like this in
grade schools there's a teacher Who
provided this book to her middle
schoolers and they called the police on
her and she was removed and he and this
is what happens
a teacher provided this book to 10 to
middle schoolers the book shows pictures
of sex acts explains extremely
disgusting activities that would cause
serious illness like okay what people
need to understand is there are
activities that people engage in when it
comes to adult stuff that will injure
you and give you infections and diseases
and I'm talking about E coli and I don't
want to be gross but let's just I'm
gonna have to describe it for y'all we
try to keep it family friendly so
earmuffs for your kids but the book
describes consuming feces okay you you
can die from things like this wait are
you serious I didn't even know that was
in there I knew this was perverse I
didn't know that oh my gosh I'm I'm
fairly certain I haven't seen that part
yet I'm fairly certain we talked about
that before I want to double check but
I'm pretty sure it talks about
yeah look maybe maybe and also maybe I
shouldn't be so surprised right because
there's a lot of perversity associated
with the this particular set of Life
Choices I I understand
where why someone might think this is a
good idea because like okay they're
thinking kids don't have enough sexual
education we need to prep these young
kids that don't have good families their
lives ahead of time it does confirm oh
my God yeah here let me see it it is in
the books for it that's it dude that is
sickening that is sickening
right and so jail what happens when uh
so to clarify though the the the
description is in the glossary
explaining what the ACT is and how to do
it so when parents see this stuff they
say hey
I don't want my kid reading that and
what happens you get that woman from the
majority report Emma being like I don't
believe in censorship I think I'm like
should this be in school it's like well
I don't agree with censorship she wants
kids to read the new master of Penthouse
should be in schools and then the
conversation just changed after that
like she didn't say yes and she didn't
really say no I don't think I don't
remember exactly but it's a good point
do you want Pet house in schools do you
want like nudie magazines and for for 13
or 14 year olds to look at there's
pictures of nude there's a drawing of a
naked woman right in there I'm like page
what I don't know 188 or something like
that like explicit with arrows pointing
to the different private parts and like
that's what kids need to understand
private parts those are private those
are for you if someone ever messes with
your privacy and your private you tell
an adult you tell your parents like that
is this kind of is
but I'm coming from a different
generation man I didn't have the
internet until I was like 14. I didn't
see porn until I was 14. I didn't and
and for young kids that see slip on to
some of that at the age of six I don't
know it's a different reality for me how
you teach kids about this kind of thing
it even has a they they drew a picture
of grinder oh my gosh like in the back
oh explains what a glory hole is on page
182 it says note grinder is explically
for 18 and up now here's how it was used
when it was brought up by the way too
she's like oh it's good and then you
guys were like well yes there's a
description of gay hookup apps and
someone was showing this at 10 year olds
and she's like why do you get these
anecdotes
it if if a child reads this and comes in
the back and comes to the dusting that
explains consuming feces you could die
why why would why would Amazon think a
14 to 17 year old should be reading
something like this and they make the
argument that oh kids have access to the
internet these days maybe they shouldn't
yeah exactly these websites are supposed
to have blocks on them you're not
supposed to allow kids to be looking at
this stuff the idea that well no kids
can see other disgusting things in other
disgusting places so let's show them
disgusting things in their school where
I they ideally should be safe from this
kind of perversity I understand it even
explains amyl nitrate
wasn't that like bath salts or is that
like how you
what is that I'm not gonna get into it
all right it's it's it's a substance
used in uh
like crazy sex parties and all that
stuff we'll leave it at that yeah yeah
man on 182 they're like Grinders
explicitly this is what I don't get I
understand you want to tell a kid ahead
of time things I gotta watch out here
are the phone numbers in the back of
organizations to call to get more
information and more access let's
discuss but there's an advocacy holy
there's a difference between warning
children about what's to come and
showing them how to do the things
they're not supposed to do right when it
says this is for 18 and up this this app
but here's how exactly how you use it
you upload a photo and it says you
upload a photo like it tells them you do
it you do this thing I'm I'm not going
to read it piece by piece it's just so
disturbing note Grindr also has an age
minimum of 18 years old it's in bold
then the next paragraph house XX or apps
sex apps work upload a tiny pic of
yourself to the app like it's for 18
year olds you don't tell them how to do
it yeah also the idea that you can get
away with something like that in a book
that's being marketed to children by
simply saying oh you have to be 18 or up
well this stuff is in schools it's being
shown to Children Amazon's selling it to
children as young as 14 years old there
was a teacher who was showing it to 10
year olds and the idea that you would
give somebody a guide on how to use
these hookup apps is if it's rocket
science and you need a guy to know how
to log in you're clearly directing these
kids to do this like you're clearly
directing them to do this
so sick so the main point was
Amazon says 14 to 17 year olds
what do you think would happen if you
went to a playground with a bunch of 14
year olds and started teaching them how
to use grinder jail you'd be arrested as
you should be yep right but there but
but when it comes to what they're doing
in schools it's all protected and then
when we ask a simple question
to to a leftist who comes on this show
comes on the culture War podcast why is
why how hard is it for them to be like
now I get it those books shouldn't be in
school
instead they say I don't believe in
censorship so allow it and I'm like what
yeah no but if you wanted to have a
Bible in a school library right it's so
funny how two-faced they are right and
it's clear that they're not interested
in either Free Speech or combating
censorship because none of them were
saying that schools not being able to
teach creationism meant that Christians
didn't have free speech all the
arguments they're making for this
perverse nonsense are arguments that
they obviously didn't make in favor of
people teaching their children their
values about the Christian faith they
weren't saying well you know when kids
get old enough they're going to learn
about Christianity anyway so we should
tell them about it now like that's kept
as far away from public schools as
possible but guidebooks that teach
children how to eat feces and use gay
hookup apps are not kept away from
schools for some reason and when someone
tries to keep it away from schools we
call them a tyrant that's where our
culture's at right now parents called
the police on a teacher who showed this
to their kids to the great to the to the
middle school kids good for them yeah
yeah this is why Target's getting hit
getting getting stocked this is why Bud
Light suffering because these companies
they're just marching along like don't
know don't care we're just gonna do
whatever we're told to do and parents
are saying no right now we we've had
enough of this stuff there was that
remember
um the uh Nick marks the the gamer when
he was like leave the kids alone and
they went nuts on them yep and uh I
guess what this the sentiment was he
recently became a father
yup now you get it now you're like how
dare you show my children these things
and parents started seeing it and now
there's a backlash I think this could be
the Dem one of the Democrats biggest
weaknesses Trump was recently in a rally
and he was like you know I could talk
his I'm paraphrasing we said something
like I talk about lowering taxes nobody
cares I talk about culture War stuff
everybody starts cheering yes
because taxes are like a boring thing we
deal with periodically and try and
figure out the right number typically we
want to go down everybody wants it to go
down but right now we're dealing with an
existential threat targeting children
this has got people riled up like crazy
yeah and and again rightfully so I'm
curious what what path forward do you
see here what do you think family should
be doing what do you think it's it's
possible to do within the guidelines of
the law also as a lawyer I mean who who
can be sued who can charges be pressed
against for these kinds of things look I
mean there's a lot of parents who are
stepping up across the country who are
are saying no more and doing things like
I mean look if you're a parent and you
have a teacher showing your kids
explicit material you should I think in
in under the right circumstances
reported to law enforcement but you also
have all kinds of other ways that you
can do things you can sue the school
district you can get the materials
demand that the materials are removed
from the libraries I mean just simple
steps showing up going to school board
meetings showing up talking to your
teachers talking to your principals
because you know ultimately you know we
are in that place I think as a culture
as a country where it is where the
societal inflection point where you know
which direction do we go do we tolerate
more of this because that's what we're
going to get if we don't stop it right
or do we say no enough is enough and so
a lot of folks are are are using the
courts using courts of public opinion to
advance the ball and try to defend not
not I wouldn't say even conservative
values I mean they are conservative
values but just traditional American
values human values things that have
been understood for millennia
and that now are just being uh tolerated
uh like that book that book is
disgusting it has no place in a school
there's a
Snopes highlighted a chap uh uh a a
section from the book I want to find it
in the book who put the notes in the
book was that wasn't character that oh
okay so maybe maybe the notes show uh no
there's uh is that it
how to argue with Sodom and Gomorrah
yeah so he and I were going before
between the show he was like reading the
supposed like these objections to the
Bible and they were all very weak
they're all very bad and also objections
the Islamic teaching on it the book
instructs people young kids I'm gonna
say kids because it's sold to 14 to 70
year olds the book instructs kids how to
argue uh against religion Christianity
Islam I want to talk about gay sex so
right at the uh beginning of the chapter
that talks talking about sex it says
this chapter is about sex therefore it
has sex in it well duh if you're a
younger reader and you feel you aren't
ready for the finer details of same-sex
pairings then simply skip this whole
chapter however before you do
I'd like to remind you that we taught
you all about straight sex when you were
11 years old during sixth grade the fact
that they didn't also teach you what
same-sex couples do is nothing less than
institutionalized homophobia straight
sex was presented as the norm to make
five percent of the population feel
abnormal is there something icky about
gay sex is there something wrong with it
I challenge any politician to discuss
this with me I will ruin them this
chapter is simply all the stuff teachers
should be saying if they want to be
inclusive of people with same-sex
feelings two things I want to point out
the first sentence the first couple of
sentences in the introduction is if you
feel you aren't ready skip this
it then says however before you do I
want to remind you meaning
if you're not ready consider why you
should read it anyway that's kind of
insane but more importantly
when we teach sex ed in schools we are
not explaining to Children how to use
bondage gear we're not teaching children
about sex clubs or apps
sex education is about reproduction
maybe I'm wrong and if it's happening it
shouldn't be but what I understand about
sex ed is it's like here the
reproductive organs here's how they work
thank you students here's the test or if
they even have one this book is
eating poop that's wild there's there's
there's other parts in there that I
can't even begin to describe I know I
want to be I want a full uncensored
discussion on this book but that is so
not hardcore sex ed that is fetish
education yeah exactly it's perversity
education and they're and they're trying
to justify it like when we taught kids
how to about General reproduction
therefore you should teach them about
eating feces like what yeah no
disgusting yeah exactly is what's making
parents say enough well and also I think
this is something people fail to realize
uh there's a conversation a very
distinctly remember having in high
school another student said to me while
we were in our sex side class and they
were being completely unironic they said
how do you think people figured this
stuff out before they had sex said they
said
people don't need to go take a class to
know how to have sex the purpose of sex
ed is to tell you what not to do right
you're going to get older you're going
to become an adult you're going to start
engaging in these activities what's
important is that when you were young
when you're developing your parents
ideally had a conversation with you
about what the boundaries are and the
things that you shouldn't be doing
because you're going to figure out what
you can do I don't think it goes that I
don't I think that's that's over the top
said when I was a kid was like here is a
diagram of the male reproductive organs
well well but when I say what not to do
by the way I'm not saying um I'm not
saying like giving people details on
these kinds of things and saying don't
do that kids I mean just telling them
this is this is sex this is what it does
it makes people and it's it's something
you should do with your spouse and now
with someone before you meet your spouse
that's what I mean by what you should
not do I was there to place a
restriction to let people know these are
the things that are going to make your
life more difficult if you do them
ideally you're going to wait until
you're married you're going to get
married you're going to have a family
don't go fooling around outside of
marriage we had a uh Super Chat earlier
someone said that they were out of booze
for the rest of the week and they were
hoping I would not say two specific
words
because they otherwise they'd have to
drink if I said these two words oh I
know what words can I say them can I
definitely definitely civil you can say
because if I say it they have to drink
but if you say it's okay just point to
me whenever you want to Civil War so we
have this tweet from Rick Scott he said
I'm warning socialists and Communists
not to travel to Florida they are not
welcome in the Sunshine State peace I'm
gonna play the clip for you
Rick Scott here let me give you a a
travel warning if you're a Socialist
Communist somebody that believes in big
government I would think twice think
twice if you're thinking about taking a
vacation or moving to Florida we're in
the free seat of Florida we actually
don't believe in socialism we actually
know people and we some people are
saying lived under it we know people
lived in our socialism is not good it's
not good for anybody so if you're
thinking about it if you think about
coming to Florida and your social
communist think twice we like Freedom
Liberty capitalism things like that say
it Civil War
kidding by the way yeah but a lot of
people were tweeting about tweeting
about it and tweeting at me yeah they're
freaking out what I can't go to the
place that I'm constantly claiming is
the worst part of America no you can't
chance you should be happy there is
something about people and he's just
telling you you won't like it no no you
can't I'm fine with them thinking they
can't there's a there's definitely an
aspect of taking things for granted in
the modern age that I don't think a lot
of people understand that if they trash
this country what kind of lockdown could
actually like what what could be lost by
the way the ability to walk around
freely and stuff like that do you think
that like if if Gavin Newsom or some
governor of a left-wing State went no
fascist so welcome here that people will
be going well he's excluding People
based on their politics so what about
tolerance what's happening whatever
happened to tolerance man I gotta
balance if if Gavin Newsom made a video
and he said Fashions are welcome in
California I'd be like okay I'd be like
how did you get elected right but like
my view is like that doesn't apply to
any of any of us right it's just a term
that means bad guy yeah so it's like
okay whatever but when when they when he
said socialism kind of aren't welcome
leftists legitimately got mad they were
like how dare you you're like why not
yeah why can't it what is this we make
everywhere we go better I saw I think it
was a tweet from Michael malison he was
just he had something about like the the
fracturing of the of the states is going
as planned or something like that I
should actually pull that one up try and
find it but yeah I mean I don't take it
seriously to be completely honest
but I do think that when you look at the
election in Florida when you look at
here's here's what Michael Mouse said
our nation's growing ideological
self-segregation is proceeding nicely
actually it's a really good point it is
people leaving California who are more
conservative leaning going to Texas and
Florida people leaving New York for the
same reason
where does the self-segregation lead to
I just love that he says he's warning
them potentially not welcome I'm warning
you you're not welcome a decentralized
Federation of State Authority I mean I
think that's kind of what we're supposed
to lead that's where we were it's where
we came from and then what happens when
you have
it's one thing when California's a
sanctuary State and they let illegal
immigrants criminal immigrants enter
their state
but then these people who enter can now
easily access any other part of the
country
so what happens when you're Arizona
dealing with a border crisis
and then California keeps their border
open lets people come in illegally and
then very easily the cross in Arizona
okay if this hyperpolarization keeps
happening Arizona sets up a border
they set up a checkpoint and they say we
have way too many people coming in from
California that we don't know if our
citizens so we're going to do a border
checkpoint and now you're going to show
your ID if you want to get through
I you know it's reasonable it's a big
inconvenience for 99.9 of the people
going from California Arizona but it's
maybe for a weekend they could try it I
don't know that's a thing this is what I
get a big cost and not that much just
administrative cost I'm thinking putting
putting putting uh a booth
I don't I I don't think it's it's that
expensive to put a couple booths on a
few highways that go in and out of the
state
they would like check the trunk of every
car that came by no they just stop and
say what's your business in Arizona
where are you headed and then I'm just
driving through them on the okay have a
nice day I see your ID kind of thing got
an ID so if you don't have an ID you
won't be able to go across stage order
I'm not saying it's a good thing I'm
saying that's where we head that's
that's where we go if we're we're
getting to the point where
you look we've already talked about how
in some of these blue States there's
child sex change sanctuaries
there's already the fear this is what
I'm worried about some kid on Tick Tock
sees all these videos
Finds A Book Like This
calls the number meets a stranger on the
internet who says I'll drive you to
Washington and get you your treatment
effectively kidnapping the kid bring
them to Washington and Washington says
it's legal
now what happens if you're in Montana or
Wyoming Wyoming is the number one Trump
supporting state in the country what
happens if you're from Wyoming and
someone takes your kid and brings them
to Washington
now you've got a very very serious
border dispute because Washington said
oh that guy who kidnapped your kid
he was doing your kid a favor and then
you say I want my kid returned to me and
they say no because you're the criminal
federal government doesn't intervene
what happens
you are going to get Wyoming being like
we're going to set up checkpoints to
make sure people aren't kidnapping
children to bring them to Washington for
for uh for lewd in lascivious reasons
yeah you just gotta have the feds the
feds are supposed to they're not going
to do it that's the only the only way to
prevent these States from going rogue is
to have Federal enforcement and
oversight you need then protect then
you're talking about stronger federal
law enforcement and we don't have that
and if anything the feds will protect
Washington and the kidnapper that's so
messed up yeah even under Trump even
under Trump trump made the mistake of
thinking that these people would operate
any differently
what do you mean who uh who are these
people the the FBI
Trump trump literally thought I can't
that dude made up so many mistakes and
trusting these people over and over and
over again yeah it was like he's on
autopilot that was weird I think he just
actually had faith in the system I think
Trump thought it was busted but he could
fix it and he saw the general good in
you in the United States I think now
it's the opposite now he's like these
people are corrupt the whole thing's
gotta go
but this is my point when we're looking
at Rick Scott jokingly say socials and
commies don't come here and then the
left actually gets mad because they
actually are socialists in commies
like we're we're heading to a dark place
how would you guys Define socialist what
would make somebody a socialist public
ownership of the means of production
yeah so so yeah communism is like worker
ownership over the means of production
and then how socialism is different from
communism changes based on who you're
talking to some say that like social I
think as a general rule when you look at
how they've operated in the world
communism usually happens because of
like some Revolution or state takeover
and socialism is usually voted in but
that's not actually definitive Well they
um some some say socialism is economic
and communism is political yeah well
people say communism encompasses
everything right so even your culture
becomes Modified by it where socialism
just refers to econ but there are a
bunch of different ways people Define it
and I've heard it defined even by
official sources multiple different ways
so it's every communist state is
socialist but every socialist state is
not necessarily communist yeah yeah I
suppose so what would that be like State
ownership is communist but if it's just
state communism is is typically
characterized by
a single party controlling everything in
like an authoritarian or thorocratic
mean
gulagging people disappearing people
socialism where the people own
everything socialism can actually
socialism is interesting because there's
like a threshold for it right
if you're looking at a spectrum you can
argue America is a capitalist country
right yeah except half of our half of
our money is taxed and goes to the
public so actually the United States is
not a capitalist economy it's a mixed
economy at a certain point
you can call it socialist or capitalist
what's that line up to you maybe 70
percent
if 70 of your income is kept by you and
30 goes to the public that's the
threshold for being a capitalist country
anything from 70 up to 100 of the money
you keep as capitalist and then anything
in between is mixed and then 70 Taxation
and higher is socialist I don't know
that to be fair it's not just about
government taxation yeah socialism is
basically like the workers own the
factory
communism is like everyone owns
everything but there's actually a
military in control and they'll execute
you if you disagree
but it it can be it can be a bit uh
vague the simple thing is socialism is
basic economics the further you go
towards the public owning everything is
the further you go towards socialism the
further you go towards private ownership
the further you go towards capitalism
and capitalism is better yeah of course
unquestionably yeah I I think also like
just in terms of how the word is usually
understood
um communism has a much more baggage
associated with it on the cultural
question which I think is part of why
people associate it with a complete
cultural takeover and because that's
also what you saw in Communist States
like the USSR or communist China
and so people people will almost view
socialism as just sort of a moderate
form of Communism but that's not really
an accurate way of looking at it either
we have a lot of people pointing out
there already are border checkpoints
some saying when you uh you generally
stop at state borders to pay tolls
already so those could easily be
modified to stop and check your ID other
people mention that there are way
stations and agricultural checkpoints
already between states I'm saying it
becomes like
country to Country effectively Arizona
is dealing with a mass influx of illegal
immigrants taxes as well
at a certain point they might just be
like we have to control our borders but
that would be like if someone because
there'll be Vans and trucks you need to
stop the van come around out back open
the van look through enough stuff the
dog walks around the truck yep
absolutely that's a lot of a lot of
Labor it sure is and I'm saying that's a
bad thing though it uh whether you think
it's good or bad is not the point what
matters is
if we are by if we are if we are
segregating to this degree it will
happen when covet happened they had
checkpoints new uh I think Connecticut
had checkpoints because they didn't want
New Yorkers fleeing because of the
lockdowns into Connecticut for Safe
Haven so they were like checking license
plates and stuff like that yo crazy and
who would have ever thought that would
have happened before covet right yeah to
your point now it's it's like
you know Europe used to have checkpoints
between the countries and then you get
the European Union in the Schengen Zone
but I think the U.S actually headed in
that direction because you're gonna
you're gonna have I think Wyoming and
Washington are a really good example I
think you got Idaho in between but so
maybe it'll be Idaho actually Otto's
pretty conservative spot and they're
going to get issues Wyoming is going to
be like why are you allowing these
people to take our kids through your
state and they're going to say okay and
why am I going to be like we expect you
to cooperate with us on law enforcement
so Idaho is going to be like we got this
Corridor that goes through goes to
Montana to Washington whatever we're
gonna set checkpoints
it's I think what is it one highway it's
probably there's probably some smaller
ones I think it's one Highway up north
yeah it's one highway I'm actually
fearful of how the federal government
might try to crack down on that
um well I could just see if you have a
regime that's as far to the left as the
one that's in power now is and that
wants to push for this mutilation of
children I can imagine them saying no
you can't uh you can't tell someone
they're not able to pass through your
state in order to get their quote
unquote gender affirming care to be to
be fair there's one Federal Highway one
bit it's I-90 right one Interstate but
then there there are a bunch of smaller
roads smaller State highways yes like to
be completely honest I can count them
yeah it's not a lot I can go all the way
all the way what are we looking at up
north you mean so from if I'm if I'm
looking at just out of Washington
you can you can man it's really nice
yeah it's rugged up there there's one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten and in winter time a lot of those
three yeah ten roads so if you got to
the point where Washington act there
actually was an issue of kids being
trafficked into Washington for child sex
changes
and States like Idaho were like no way I
mean actually Let's Lose Idol as an
example relatively conservative place
they don't want their kids being brought
there so what all they need is 10
checkpoints 10. yo that's 20 guys
20 guys on rotation work in a border
yeah and like I said in the winter time
a lot of those places are not even you
can't navigate them they're like
coverage so there's no way through it's
mostly it's gonna be one or two roads
they might exit to another state you'd
have to have your entire border blocked
off or covered yeah no in it's ten roads
the whole the whole border they're just
talking about the Western going going
east yes if you're in Washington it is
10 roads out of Washington you have to
go south well they said Idaho okay into
Idaho yeah so Washington into Idaho
there are 10 roads there's probably many
smaller ones but there are 10 main roads
one main interstate highway and then I
think a couple State highways and I
counted on the map zooming in even to
the small ones it looks like it's about
10. so I'm not saying I know for a fact
it will happen I'm saying if this is the
path we head down
abortion is also a big issue what
happens if I've talked about it before
yeah you got you got a man and a woman
they're together they're maybe married
they they get pregnant start fighting
woman says I need to leave this guy for
whatever reason
and he says I forbid you from getting an
abortion and she's you can't
Idaho doesn't allow it so then she goes
to Washington
and he goes to the state and says she's
kidnapped my child a better example is
states that have completely banned it I
think like what Oklahoma banned it
outright is it Oklahoma who banned it
outright Texas Texas uh are you sure let
me double check on that
um yeah I mean after I mean no no no no
there's been I think Oklahoma was a
total ban yeah I mean it might have been
Oklahoma had the total pain it looks
like there are so
um New York Times actually has a tracker
for which states have done a complete
outright ban so a full ban in effect
versus six week Banner it doesn't look
like you said Idaho or did you say no no
Oklahoma yes Oklahoma does have a
full-on band full-on band that's also if
we're going to go with the and then
Colorado right um so let's say someone
uh there's a couple in Oklahoma
something happens and the woman says you
know what I just don't want to have this
baby because it'll it'll it'll keep me
locked with this guy
Colorado is it's it's right on the this
is crazy they they they they they share
a border Colorado let's see is uh what
road do we got here 385 Campo to Boise
City
so you can have a woman who's in
Oklahoma
drive 100 miles across the border into
Colorado where there's no restriction at
all
what happens when that father says my
unborn son has been kidnapped and is
going to be executed what does Oklahoma
do to prevent that from happening
nothing the federal government won't do
anything either you're going to have
border checkpoints and Oklahoma's going
to be like ma'am
why are you leaving why are you going to
Colorado
there's going to be Syria just outright
and even the left agrees on this one
because the left has talked about this
that they're going to be trying to stop
women from fleeing to get abortions in
states where it's illegal yep I think
that what I brought up you need border
if you're going to do that you need like
Border Protection on the entire state of
Oklahoma because although it does share
a border with Colorado in one spot
people could go through like New Mexico
no West and then go north or they could
go south and then West the north to
avoid that border and they can get on
the plane the point of Kansas and then
West into Colorado so you would need a
robust no you wouldn't border patrol you
are incorrect if you're trying to
prevent people from leaving the state
that is not the way to go they're
they're going to try and prevent
specifically the the the trafficking for
the purpose of abortion but how would
how would you would have to get her to
say she's doing it at the border
crossing too and why would you just be
like no we're just I'm just going on a
vacation Ian I think you misunderstand
that's irrelevant they you will get
enough people in Oklahoma
who will be like we demand a checkpoint
it's like facial recognition eye
scanning and like DNA you misunderstood
you completely misunderstand Simpson's
bear Patrol you guys remember that yeah
yeah a bear one day wanders through
Springfield so they all panic and demand
a bear Patrol and get it it doesn't
matter what you think they need to do
need is immaterial if enough people say
you know I I I had a girlfriend she got
pregnant and then she she crossed the
board to get an abortion and now my son
is dead was killed or my daughter was
killed they will just vote and the state
will do it and sure you could argue it's
ineffective that's not the point the
point is people will say it and it will
have to happen you cannot have two
states side by side where one is totally
banned abortion and one has totally
unrestricted abortion it is very obvious
what will happen Oklahoma will say to
these women it is illegal to get an
abortion the women will then be like I'm
going to Colorado and they'll say we're
setting up a checkpoint at the border of
Colorado and then we're gonna arrest you
I mean yes it's illegal arrestor for one
it's illegal they totally what's illegal
it's crossing the border okay Ian you
don't get it I 100 get it she has not
got an abortion at this day of
illegality you're claiming okay so
what's illegal so when
there there is a prosecution
okay Donald Trump let's use the Trump is
an example did Trump break the law with
classified documents
yes or no no
Hillary Clinton had classified documents
she wasn't prosecuted
Joe Biden has classified documents he
wasn't prosecuted Donald Trump has
classified documents he does get
prosecuted so what's the crime it
doesn't matter a state prosecutor will
find something on the book show me the
man show me the crime my point is if
Oklahoma says it is illegal and a woman
trafficks an unborn baby for the purpose
of terminating its life they will say
they will treat it as if it's murder
period yeah but they'll say this is
unknown that's the point that I'm making
they they argue this in court this is
the purpose of an indictment and a
criminal trial so you you can't make the
argument that you drove the car at a
high speed crashed into a person and
they died and say well I mean you could
certainly make the argument they'll be
like we don't know exactly why they did
it yep you do that you did okay you did
the woman will come back from Colorado
having gotten an abortion and they'll
say now we know exactly she goes back to
the state yeah she's probably gone out
right yeah bro I'm telling you but a
wrestling at the border I don't know
about that you cannot have these two
states coexisting this way yeah the left
made this argument that states will
start setting up like police forces
because it's illegal
not even not even not even not even an
original opinion from me I'm like I
agree with what they're saying it feels
like a dumb heavy-handed this thing to
say we'll just put cops there and then
it will stop like No One Believes that
how how deep do you want to know No One
Believes that Ian No One Believes that
we'll just stop because I put cops there
they're saying we want Cops to try and
do something because the only thing
people ever say is do something do
something so they'll do something and
that's what you can be worse than doing
nothing absolutely but I think most
people would argue it's not worse than
doing nothing because you'll get a lot
of people in Oklahoma who are like we
need to go get an abortion and the cops
are going to be at the border and
they're gonna be like I can't do this
turn around
or there'll be like people will be like
we suspect she may get an abortion we
have an anonymous tip let's tap her
phone lines
you are right
now I don't know yeah I don't know I
don't think I don't think Oklahoma
criminalizes the woman though they
criminalize the practice so I think the
doctor is the one who gets in trouble
but that what you need to understand is
I am not talking about the the world is
not a machine that like human
civilization is not a machine that
functions on logic
I I love this idea when it comes to to
business contracts I hear all the time
from people who don't know how to run
businesses and they seem to think
I can't remember what movie I was
watching it was like someone had a
contract of the company and then they
their their whole like their their whole
company got seized or something happened
and they were like this is absurd how
could our company be taken over this way
and then they went to the court and the
judge was like I'm sorry it's right here
in the contract and they're like no no
and I'm like courts don't work that way
like you can come to an agreement with
someone and a judge can nullify it
judges are human beings they can be like
this is ridiculous people seem to think
that contract law and and legality is
like
I'm sorry sir it says right here there
are Judges who literally have imprisoned
children for cash
regardless of what the law says we know
human judges basically can do what they
want to do they can hold you in contempt
and lock you up and just end your life
basically and then you can bag they can
do these things
there there are Judges look Trump is the
perfect example let's let's let's jump
to the Trump story let's talk about
Donald Trump it's a perfect segue here's
the story from Fox News Trump reacts
after leaked recording shows him
discussing classified documents former
president tells Fox News digital he did
nothing wrong in secret document case I
have the audio here let's play it sick
people but that was your cue you know
against you well it started right at the
time when Millie's talking about oh
you're gonna try and do it no they were
trying to do that before you even were
sworn in that's right trying to
overthrow your life well with Millie uh
let me see that I'll show you an example
he said
that I wanted to attack Iran
isn't it amazing to have a big pile of
papers this thing just came up look
this was him
they presented me this is off the Record
but they presented me this this was him
this was the defense department in him
wow we looked at some this was him this
wasn't done by me this was him all sorts
of stuff it's pages long
wait a minute let's see here anyway
yeah I just found isn't that amazing
this totally wins my case you know
except it is like highly confidential
secretive there's a secret information
look at this you attack and Hillary
would print that out all the time
I should send it to Anthony Weiner
by the way is that incredible yeah I was
just saying because we're talking about
it and you know he said he wanted to
attack Iran and what he's in the face
this was done by the military given to
me
um I think we can probably yeah we'll
have to see yeah we'll have to try to
figure out see this President I could
have did last year no I can't you know
but this is yeah
isn't that interesting yeah it's so cool
I mean it's so I'm look we here and I
have
and you probably almost didn't believe
me but now you believe me no I believe
it's incredible so there you go that's
basically it and here's why I brought
this up for one it is is it is a big
story but my point is this Hillary
Clinton had top secret information on a
private servers she had her phone
smashed with hammers and she used an
open source purging software to destroy
all those public records Comey said no
reasonable prosecutor would bring these
charges Joe Biden had classified
documents in multiple locations maybe
they'll bring charges against him
doesn't seem likely but Hillary is the
really obvious one before an election
Comey said no we're not going to do that
that's ridiculous and she wasn't even
the president Donald Trump has
classified documents and they say give
him 10 years the view is is screaming
lock him up 10 years
this is the point about anything
pertaining to legality or law it doesn't
matter what you think is right and what
should be done what matters is people
with power wielded the left certainly
understands that the right has this
problem of being like you know but is it
allowed and the left is just like do it
anyway and that's where we're at the
Biden doj going after Trump on charges
that the Obama doj would not bring
against Hillary Yeah well yeah I kind of
want can I ask you a few questions about
this just a lawyer absolutely so when
Trump says I could have Declassified
them or should have Declassified them is
that an admission that he didn't
declassify them properly and is that
going to be held against him well look I
think that one of the things that we're
all missing is the context of these
papers that you can hear in the
background what is it that he's actually
looking at what and what is he what is
he actually flipping through right I
mean it's it's it's you know is he
flipping through some kind of a
description is he uh flipping through
some kind of a picture I mean we don't
know what was actually in front of them
but I think one of the things that that
matters here is what Tim just pointed
out which was Donald Trump was the
president of the United States Hillary
Clinton was only the Secretary of State
uh you know Joe Biden the records that
he's talking about are records he got as
vice president
or previously as a senator right and so
classified documents are controlled by
the president of the United States
documents are only classified secret top
secret confidential because of an
executive order from the president of
the United States all classification
Authority derives from the president
with one limited exception set by
Congress about Atomic atomic energy
related documents and and so you have
this whole kind of that that's one angle
and a lot of people have been talking
about that but one of the things that I
think is an interesting thought that I
hope folks start to think through
is you have all this discussion right
now about
oh my goodness president Trump violated
the presidential records act and those
weren't his documents and he couldn't
have those documents those are the
people's documents and I'm sorry for me
from coming from a first principle
standpoint under the Constitution
the Congress of the United States has no
authority to tell the president of the
United States which papers are his and
which papers aren't right that is
ultimately under the Constitution the
president of the United States has to
have that power to decide which
documents are his and so if he has that
power then how can he and then he takes
those documents with him which is the
standard practice of presidents for
almost 200 years George Washington took
his papers with him after he left office
it was actually the subject of a court
case later on uh down the line but he he
deeded them to his nephew so so how is
it now that we fast forward and Congress
passes this presidential records act in
1978 Jimmy Carter signs into law and
says oh well these are all the people's
records and the president no longer has
you know kind of an ultimate say so if
the president possesses the documents
from the first instance and has that
absolute authority to to do so then how
can he be prosecuted under the Espionage
Act for unlawful possession of these
documents it's insane I mean it just
doesn't make sense but not only that
first
we're gonna we're gonna find out in a
week or so that there's something more
to this video where like right after
this clip Trump goes I mean these aren't
actually any of the real documents the
real these are just you know memos it'll
be something like that right and you'll
be like oh I wonder why that context
wasn't provided because the media does
this all the time but then let's get
down to it let's get let's get down to
it first
what does this audio prove if anything
Donald Trump is an idiot maybe is that
it is it criminal it's not I I'll tell
you in two seconds Trump's legal team is
going to be like he was bragging he was
lying they're not it's not real
those are the document the papers you
hear that audio won't even real real
papers where was this audio recorded oh
it was in this room the papers were in a
different place the whole time
you you can't see anything you can't
hear anything someone's saying something
about look at these papers their secret
doesn't prove he actually had secret
papers and showed them to anybody right
so it's it's circumstantial at best it
does it is bad for Trump don't get me
wrong yeah but they're acting like it's
this big bombshell and my thing is you
know what I think I think Trump was just
speaking off the coffin and being a
braggart and then when it actually came
down to the legal matter he said look
I'm the president they're Declassified
because I say so and that's his argument
now I don't think this tape does
anything all that's going to happen is
if you're on the left you're going to
think it's a bombshell if you're on the
right you're gonna say it's stupid as
and I'll tell you this
if the left says Trump must get 10 years
for this actually they do they do let me
pull up the the little little article
here we got from mediaite lock him up
already The View gets wild as host
suggests Trump selling docs predicted
gets 10 years in prison okay
all right I'm down yeah you know
Hillary's next in line let's get it and
now of course we can get Obama on that
killing that 16 year old American
citizen bring them all right bring them
all let's lock them all up she said
don't bite it next he was selling
documents I mean it's just these people
are insane oh
but the point is
the reason why this tape doesn't matter
is because we know Hillary Clinton had
top secret information
we know that she had no authority to
have it we know that she had uh phones
with the records on them destroyed with
hammers
we know that she had uh the per the
server purged with bleach bit and Comey
said no reasonable prosecutor would
bring charges on this so then
am I supposed to think it's reasonable
for Trump to be charged no of course not
well I'm I'm curious again as a lawyer
what do you think this does in a court
of law like this kind of evidence I mean
it it really depends on what gets
admitted and there's all kinds of tests
for what gets admitted and what gets
heard and what the the jury can see
assuming it goes to a jury
um but again Tim's exactly right his
lawyers go in and they start punching
holes in this well how do you know what
documents was he talking about do we
have witnesses who can recall and take
the stand and they'll tell Oh They'll
testify oh yeah it was this precise
document that was Mark marked top secret
no foreign uh you know your eyes only uh
document and he was showing us all of
these precise battle Plants now I mean I
I very highly doubt that in in Tim's
exactly right every time we see one of
these things play out which is I think
what the most Americans recognize now
is that every time we see one of these
allegations it's whether it's three days
or three years down the line
there's more to the story and the the
left just keeps coming at him and coming
at him and coming at him with everything
that they have and it's always this is
the last straw this is the death knell
for Donald Trump the walls are closing
the walls are closing in and every time
there's more to it indeed I think that
the left is destroying its own
credibility the more that they do this
because the average Americans sitting at
home Kansas Georgia you know Nevada
wherever they see this and they say why
do they keep going after this guy this
doesn't make sense like they just keep
coming after him it's it it just it's
counterintuitive it doesn't make any
sense to that I do want to give a
special shout out to Donald Trump for
trusting the corporate press all the
time
he just he just he just loves allowing
these people to come in all the time and
just let him record him and all this
stuff
he keeps giving them interviews it's
wonderful isn't it
I I don't get that's the part of it that
I don't get I never got it to go back to
the channel That the initial segue to
this this is my point when we were
talking about the borders and Oklahoma
Banning abortion Colorado allowing it it
doesn't matter what you think the law is
we talked about the other day
cohabitation in West Virginia is illegal
are they going to bring charges against
you only if they want to search your
residence
show me the man I'll show you the crime
so let's say you're in West Virginia and
you're an activist and the states like
this person's causing us problems can we
find a crime that will give us a
justification for searching their
residents they're cohabitating that's
illegal boom we got them I still want to
look up that law I haven't been able to
find it so like cohabitation is in
living with someone of the opposite sex
you're not married with or in a
relationship with Boost
for like I couldn't find the law
um yeah I I agree it's not about doing
what's right but the reason I was
concerned with the whole setting up
border checkpoints thing is because I
I'm looking ahead at what problems that
could arise from a social movement to
install border patrol whether or not
it's legal whether or not it's righteous
that it could end up causing more
unnecessary spying on the the people
themselves that on you know unexpectedly
they didn't realize what they had
Unleashed on themselves by creating some
sort of patrol office around them
you try to be pulling up that law yeah
it's uh this is weird so yeah how long
is this lewd and lascivious cohabitation
when persons presumed to be unmarried is
the law 61-8-4
but it does say whether married or not
afterwards
interesting oh so like you're doing lewd
and lascivious things even within the
context of marriage they're basically
saying you're being a freak right get
out of my bedroom yeah and yeah yeah
yeah it's it's yeah
okay so to be to be specific it's not
it's not about just cohabitation it's
about fornication it says um it says in
in prosecutions for adultery and
fornication lewd and lasciviously
cohabiting together the person's name in
the indictment shall be presumed to be
unmarried persons unless proof to the
contrary so
I I I'm assuming that the laws oh
fornication means unmarried sexual
intercourse that's the first yeah I
never put that together I think I think
what they're saying I could be wrong but
I was talking to someone about it
recently and they were like yeah what
are they called they're called blue laws
or whatever they're archaic laws nobody
no they don't enforce them but this is
like if you're making a noise violation
with your lady and you're not married
they might be like yo
stop and if you don't stop and you don't
stop and you're gonna stop they're like
hey okay I get it now if any person's
not married to each other lewdly and
lasciviously Associate or cohabitate
together they shall be guilty of a
misdemeanor and upon conviction be fine
not less than fifty dollars yeah like
that to clarify if you are not married
and you'd be hooking up it's illegal and
it's like I think that's particularly if
you're hooking up in public like they
can no no no no no no people can sense
that you're doing it inside like they
walk by to hear the noise they see it in
a window because lewdness they wouldn't
know unless they were there it actually
clarifies or whether married or not be
guilty of open gross lewdness that's a
separate separate Clause so what I read
was specifically saying if you are not
married and you are lewdly associating
and cohabitating
then you will be guilty of a misdemeanor
if you are married or not and uh
be be guilty of open or gross lewdness
and lasciviousness you will be guilty of
a misdemeanor
so anyway that's my point yeah they
don't prosecute that stuff anymore but I
guess I'm actually if they tried to
today though if they're if they were
going after somebody they didn't like
and then this was the justification it
would almost certainly be struck down no
court would convince them that's there's
an issue lewd is such a vague term also
but all all laws use terms you struggle
to Define and then a judge interprets it
that's crazy Wicked it means Wicked so
let me explain Ian a woman is in
Oklahoma abortion is totally banned it's
a total ban right
Ian I mean let me yeah so yes yes if
there is so the place is yes yeah
exactly Oklahoma does have a total ban
now now what we'll need is a judge's
interpretation of what then would you
call taking a pregnant woman carrying a
child that the state deems to be a child
across state lines without permission of
the other parent would that be
kidnapping
yeah what I'm saying is if this can can
uh continues in this way
you will get to the point where the
interpretation of the state in Oklahoma
is that a child carried to another state
for to be put to death does it is
irrelevant whether it's in the womb or
out of the womb if a woman carried a
physical child across state lines to
bring it to a place to have it killed
they would view it identically to a
woman with the baby in the womb doing
the same thing yeah I'm actually curious
about the law I want to look into it but
I'm not sure if the laws that are
Banning it are also defining it as
homicide I wonder if some states without
characterizing it as harmless that's why
I'm saying a judge you'll have to
interpret it yeah because if you this
this is inevitable not that a judge will
say homicide but that the interpretation
will have to be have to be handed down
by a judge you will get a circumstance
in Oklahoma and it's probably already
happened where a woman gets pregnant
goes to Colorado gets an abortion
there will be a lawsuit or some
challenge if slice when she returns and
you will have some you know you will
have the father or some family member
being like that was illegal and then
filing some kind of claim and demanding
criminal charges for it it's an illegal
act to terminate the pregnancy she went
and did it another state what will the
judges say about that it'll have to be
interpreted by somebody
yeah I think Oklahoma based on this
trajectory will lean towards it is child
trafficking and murder
that's why child trafficking is
interesting because if like an
eight-month if a woman's eight months
pregnant and she's like hey I'm going to
see my mom in in another state and the
dad's like no you're not not this week
she's like uh yeah I am I have the
tickets already and he's like no you're
not going anywhere and she's like I'm
leaving and she leaves and it's like
she's trafficking a child the dad goes
to the court absolutely that's yup no
that woman has every right to go to her
mom's house across state lines in my
opinion and then with an eight-month-old
in womb and and that person and then two
two things happen one yes there will be
circumstances where women will be
unjustly halted from living their lives
the second there will be women who will
lie about traveling to visit their
parents in order to terminate the life
of the child
hmm
yeah I mean also if if you're pregnant
um if you just have a child in general I
think it would be very strange for you
to go somewhere without your spouse
wanting you to go there I'm sure you
have like some abusive relationships
where the husband is a maniac and the
woman has a reason to leave but that's
that's totally different
I think we're headed towards uh as the
state's fracture you don't say is this
the word I have to say yeah the phrase I
have to say I think so I wasn't going to
say anything oh you're jumping the gun
okay okay I'm gonna say something
something dark because it starts with
the the the political polarization of of
people into certain States then the
championing of of uh federalization like
States being Sovereign but but then you
have to contend with the fact that if
Colorado and Oklahoma are distinct
entities with very with extremely
different laws you will need border
checkpoints
this is the this is the fracturing of
the United States
the point where Oklahoma will have to
have a border checkpoint with Colorado
yeah it's also very um it's very
interesting because I I wonder in 20
years where all of these states are
going to be we've seen States change
from red to blue over time and it's
possible look the entire country in in
many ways especially on social issues
has moved significantly further to the
left in terms of legislation I would say
in some states abortion and uh in
general gun control are kind of the two
issues where we've moved to the right is
a country but for the most part the
trajectory has always been to the left
I'm I'm curious to see if there's going
to be a backlash in some of these places
that are blue might start to turn red
that's also again not me saying that's
going to happen I think that could be
wishful thinking but on the point of
immigration to to uh add to what you're
saying Ian
they already do have random stops
in States when I when I first went to
California I went I entered through San
Diego from from the Tijuana no no no
from Arizona into California to San
Diego and uh I was on a bus from San
Diego to LA and we got randomly stopped
by immigration
and they boarded the the the the bus and
they demanded everyone pull up their
pull out their IDs and I pull up my ID
and they go and they look and they hand
the things bang handed back and they
came up to me and the guy looks at my ID
and he goes what's your favorite
baseball team
and I was like I don't like baseball
he's gonna go to favorite baseball team
and I was like well I'm from Chicago I
could say the Sox I guess but I don't
really watch baseball and he goes you're
fine hands me the ID back the reason he
asked that is he wanted a fast question
that you'd have to be able to answer
really really quickly because if you're
an illegal immigrant you wouldn't have a
canned response to it so they already do
stuff like this if Arizona is worried
about the southern border crisis
if Gary Lake got elected governor she
would have to answer the question of the
illegal immigrants coming from
California not just Mexico I saw a video
uh uh from Jorge Ventura on the border
and there was like immigrants are coming
up but they couldn't get across they're
stuck at some wall or something they've
been there for three days just camping
on the border waiting to get across dude
what is the what is the solution to this
this sport I mean there isn't I don't
even want to say it online man I just
have such horrible horrible visions of
what could happen if we don't stem the
tide we have to I mean in in really
this is not overstating things but in
the Trump Administration towards the end
of the Trump Administration they had
solved the Border crisis
right the number of illegal entries
successful illegal entries which is the
goal of every illegal alien is just to
get into the United States it doesn't I
mean they don't care if they get
captured or if they sneak across or
whatever their goal is to get released
yeah their goal is to get released in
the interior so they can work they can
provide for their family whatever send
money back home that's that's their end
goal and so under the Trump
Administration what ended up happening
was these policies like remain in Mexico
where you had to say hey look we caught
you but now you're going to wait in
Mexico if you have a court claim you
want to make you're going to make it
from Mexico we're going to let you into
for your court date but other than that
you wait there that dried everything up
because people realize you don't
actually get your end goal what this
Administration is doing is you know they
were letting in all kinds of folks all
kinds of folks were coming in because
they were just catching and releasing
everybody but now what they've done is
they've done a paradigm shift where
they're directing people to the ports of
entry and they're trying to hide the
ball from the American people so they
say oh the numbers but between our ports
a number of people crossing illegally
they're going down they're still
astronomically High
those numbers are going down but instead
what they're doing is they're sending
them to the ports of entry and they say
go to the Port of Entry and make your
case there and uh what the government is
doing is by the tens of thousands every
month actually letting people come to
the Port of Entry make an appointment
tell them who they are and they just let
them into the United States well you can
go to your court date someday five years
in the future it's insane it has to stop
no country can sustain this type of
influx nobody can you think like keeping
them in Mexico was is the best solution
or just keeping them on the other side
of the Border it happens to be Mexico
you have to either do that you have to
detain people long enough for them to
have some kind of a court hearing um to
adjudicate if they have some kind of a
claim or you have to Avail them of all
other Alternatives like save their
country agreements that we'd signed with
mix uh with uh uh Guatemala El Salvador
and Honduras where it's a hey look
you're seeking a sound in the United
States and you're from Guatemala well
guess what you should have sought it
first in El Salvador or you should have
thought at first in Mexico whatever the
case may be I have an idea what if we
got
a big island
and that was like a waypoint if people
entered they get brought there for for
temporary holding so here's here's the
issue
it's easy to be like if they illegal
enter the country turn them around you
can't because what if they're not
Mexican they come to the southern border
and they're Honduran we can't then go
hey Mexico we're putting this person
into your country they might say like no
you can't do it where another person
came from and sometimes for a lot of
these people we don't even know if they
came through Mexico they may have come
through other ways they may have flown
here overstate their Visas so what if we
had an island where it's like uh if you
enter here illegally we will detain you
transport you to this this island where
you will be uh detained temporarily
until we can figure out what country you
originate from figure out proper means
of deportation or if it's a genuine uh
um case of Asylum now I think that makes
sense because you can't just push them
back and the challenge will be of course
finding the appropriate location but I
think there is an island up in the
Northeast somewhere that we could
potentially use that's very nice yeah
and you know it's it's a point
associated with grapes
no yes not Long Island no uh uh you know
maybe
um a Vineyard of something yeah yeah I
think it'd be very nice I actually
really like that idea they have plenty
of resources they care for these people
too in fact diversity is our strength I
I think I I actually think that Martha's
Vineyard can't afford not to have maybe
very strong sent there with all that it
makes them very strong it'd be good for
their economy all the things that they
say are are true for the United States
you know should be true for for Martha's
Vineyard let's set him there in fact
part I think it would be even a little
bit greedy of Martha's Vineyard to just
accept all of the the migrants but you
know what
I'm willing to give them uh be nice and
and do that in the favor
they deserve it they're good people up
there they're good people yeah let's
let's give them I want to point out I
actually pulled up the actual West
Virginia code 52102 lewd or lascivious
cohabitation no person's not married to
each other shall ludely and lasciviously
Associate and cohabitate together or
whether married or not be guilty of open
or gross lewdness or lasciviousness
quite literally you cannot live with
another person and engage in adult
activities with them unless you're
married
I wonder if uh if people have only fans
accounts or do porn from West Virginia
if they could get arrested under that
one that's open yeah that's outright
yeah so we were looking at these laws
because they were doing drag shows with
kids and I'm like pretty sure it's
already illegal uh Jefferson County
explicitly banned it saying like this is
explicitly defined as you know against
the law Berkeley County which is a
little further west it's not explicit
but West Virginia state law clearly
covers having a drag performance and
allowing kids on stage the question is
will the
AG
actually do anything about it
yeah I guess we'll have to see
we'll have to see if Law and Order means
anything I'd like to take that lewd law
off the books in West Virginia that'd be
like a big laws should Sunset I feel
yeah exactly that one yeah it's too
vague you're gonna have an uphill battle
the people of West Virginia will never
let you remove that if you have an
indecent relationship with your living
girlfriend they're gonna give you a
that's crazy that they could charge you
with a misdemeanor based but I think
it's only like a 50 fine right is that
what it said it's not like that like up
to six months in jail up to six months
oh my goodness 50 or six months I think
that's what it says it was like
pre-inflation numbers
let me uh
six uh not less than six
see that's the thing 50 bucks is a lot
of money back I know I know yeah
not less than fifty dollars not
seriously shall be fine that's how you
know it's old Shelby fined and not less
than 50 and May in the discretion of the
Court be in prison not exceeding six
months and upon repetition of the
offense they shall upon conviction be
confined not less than six uh months or
more than 12. wow wow I mean it outright
says fornication too I would love to see
the stats from historical stats to see
just how many actual of those
prosecutions were brought against
cohabitating couples versus how many
times it was used to prosecute things
like uh prostitution houses or other
things that you know that was their way
of getting at it back in the day that I
mean that would be my uh supposition but
I don't know you know what's funny is if
you go back like a hundred years when
this law is on the books you've got some
conservatives sitting around a pub table
being like these liberals they're
they're advocating for fornication in
the privacy of their own homes that's
illegal and it actually was and people
did it and now it's not illegal it's
still illegal but nobody enforce it and
a court will probably not uphold it if
they tried to arrest someone for it you
know the court would not have pulled
that today right but it's on the books
but so I mean you tell me though if you
know if your client called you saying
they were getting charged with this
would you panic would you be like I
don't know if I can go to this one do
you think you do it wow is that not
social erosion though well I mean
certainly certainly it is it's a social
erosion social uh cohesion is always
found in societies where you share a set
of values and whatever those values are
those are the values that are shared by
the community right and we can judge
them by today's standards and but uh we
shouldn't
um you they there was at least a shared
unified idea that there was some kind of
fundamental truce and some baseline
morals that everybody agreed to and They
Carried forth those that's what enables
people to have trust in relationships
and with each other and build
communities and when you erode those
things and when you do things like when
we have these drag shows with with kids
coming in uh coming to them and parents
bringing their kids to these things that
erodes all of that rapidly and we can
see we can see the immediate effects but
I think the downstream effects the
Ripple effects are the things that we
haven't yet seen that are the tears in
the fabric of our society that we're
going to see down the line as a result
of this that we're not even experiencing
it in in today's reality absolutely
agreed and you made this point you said
I don't think we should judge the people
of that time by our moral Norms quite
frankly I think it would be much more
painful to be judged in our time by
their moral Norms like social cohesion
or like shared morality should we have
that on a global scale I don't know that
you can have it on a global scale yeah I
don't think so like where does it where
does it segment righteously it used to
be every state and then it was like now
we have the United States so it has
moral but like does it ever did it ever
really have a true a real moral shared
moral value in the United States or was
it always like pockets of I think so
disparate morale I mean I think it was
you know judeo-christian kind of
protestant ethos uh that that formed
kind of the core of the common values in
the United States They Carried forth
things for a couple hundred years and
now of course as the more those died
down and religion was
people will worship something yep and
it's a matter of what are they
worshiping right and so it used to be
they would worship they would go to
church they would have a different
religion maybe they would be Baptist
maybe they would be methodists whatever
but religion in that traditional sense
for many people especially on the left
side of the spectrum has been replaced
with worship of things like transgender
ideology
the self and if it's what are you
worshiping what are you following you're
following something you just don't mind
not know what it is and they so if
you're not following if you're not
worshiping uh you're you're god
um you're worshiping something else and
a lot of times it comes down to money
and for a lot of people you know
unfortunately a lot of kids these days
as we see the statistics bear out with
the number who are self-identifying as
lgbtq IA plus plus or whatever the
acronym is these days well I just saw a
thing today it said 20 of like gen Z
kids identify as being a member of that
of that group that's not coming from a
place of of a share are you know
morality shared set of values where
where things are acceptable and things
are not acceptable that's coming from a
sense of worshiping self worshiping the
latest thing the the ever shifting Norms
of the left and they're not Tethered to
anything they're always going to be
moving to the left there's no core
anchor that holds them together kind of
like conservatives there's at least some
common values that we we hold and that
we will always it'll be our Mooring that
we won't stray far from theirs is always
shifting always moving yeah no I I think
that's right and what what I would say
is when you look at a very broad social
scale you know people did believe
different things in different areas but
anywhere where things have functioned
with a very large group do people at
least shared the natural law The Ten
Commandments but then they had their own
kind of regional Customs I think there
are laws that are universally applicable
that that all humans should follow but
then there are certain kind of regional
laws and you know built atop those
universal laws in different Regional
stories and in myths and pastimes that
can't scale out to groups that are too
large like there are certain things that
historically traditionally and
culturally make more sense for Tennessee
than California or vice versa so you
can't have a universal social cohesion
in the sense that everyone's on board
with all of the same stories and Customs
but I think you can you can ideally have
a moral code which is adhered to by
everyone in the world I just think it's
unlikely like I think it's very unlikely
that everyone's going to follow the ten
commandments we want them to every
culture should expect that but even that
it probably won't happen so that's why
when it comes to smaller things that are
are more Regional I mean I don't think
there's any hope of exporting that stuff
we we did that one episode where we went
through the Ten Commandments and we were
talking about from a secular perspective
whether they would apply to making a
better life and I think like the only
one that doesn't apply to a secular life
is keeping the lord's name and not using
the lord's name in vain but like not
killing not stealing not adultery
honoring your parents
whether you're religious or not
following those rules you will have a
better life yeah well and the thing
about the Ten Commandments is they're
they're not just specific rules they're
also categories so taking the lord's
name in vain
um in in the most real sense condemns
taking the lord's name in vain but
there's other things we extrapolate from
that just like using language properly
in property using foul languages like a
lesser violation of that commandment but
still a violation so I think even that
would apply let's go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends and head over to timcast.com
become a member we're gonna have a
members only uncensored show coming up
for you just about 10 p.m and if you've
been a member for at least six months or
you sign up at the 25 per month level
you can submit questions and even call
into the show and uh talk to us and our
guest all right I'm not your buddy guy
says not to be too hyperbolic but is
this America's last election I mean can
you imagine sharing a nation with two
vastly different ideologies it's as if
only a Julius Caesar character can save
the West
I don't know about last election but I
do believe we are entering a very
tumultuous period with this election
think about it in a couple of different
ways Will trump supporters vote to
santis I would say two to two to one no
will the Santa supporters vote for Trump
two to one no you know why I think this
they've said it descended supporters
have outright said on Twitter if it's
Trump we're not voting
well okay what about Joe Biden RFK Jr it
is so divisive
that it is just going to be chaos will
Democrats accept Trump Victory no Will
trump support accept the Democrat
Victory no where we go after this I
don't know
it seems like I don't disagree a Julius
Caesar character like we're entering it
feels like we're at that cross of the
Rubicon moment from the Republic to the
Empire officially we're always
vulnerable to it but I it strikes me
more like we're in another sexual
Revolution that's less violent than the
one that happened in the 60s but there's
more media coverage so the little bits
of violence that do happen get blown out
of proportion sexual I would say it's
like another sexual Revolution with all
this trans ideology being pushed in
schools and things like that I I I oh
sorry I'll go for it no no I mean I
agree I I agree
um I don't except I would say I don't
think it's another sexual Revolution so
much as it is the inevitable Fallout
from the first and I actually think it's
more violent the violence is just being
done to children I agree with you James
but how are you doing
violence but it is explicitly violent I
mean you've got people going around
smashing things destroying things it's
violent out on the streets in the 60s it
was pretty bad I didn't realize it and
every once in a while I hear about like
how much there was like terrorism The
Weather Underground like bombs like it
was crazy violent back then with a lot
of death
I think the Weather Underground only
killed what like a couple people they
were more about structural damage and it
was shock and all late late in the night
to scare people and terrify us like
overt terrorism but for the amount of
fear that people have been whipped into
in the last five years that is not that
violent the system has doesn't seem that
violent I get really I'll watch a
violent video and then I'll find I watch
it three or four times and I'm like did
I just watch four bouts of violence even
though it was the same thing four times
because I feel like it happened four
times now all of a sudden
all right let's uh let's grab some more
Super chats Raymond g Stanley Jr says
Tim my guy some good news your call to
create culture has is being heard I got
a sneak peek at salty draws comic book
silence do good it slaps I really think
you and others will dig it right on very
very glad to hear it we we need to get
that we got we got we need someone to
run the Grant Program however we're
doing I have no idea like I say these
things like here's the thing I want to
do and then it doesn't happen because
like someone has to run the program but
we want to do a thing where once a month
we give 10 grand to someone for their
cultural endeavor
and you know a lot of people are like
I'm gonna do a podcast and it's like you
know like this
you know it's like you're gonna paint
something or do a series of paintings or
something or you're a comic or music or
I don't know
we one thing we definitely want to do is
more bands for uh trash House Records so
we have another song in the works but we
are working on uh signing a very large
uh musical Enterprise and then we're
looking at a few others too so we're
really excited for that
all right what do we got
Dina Dino kurosi says Mr Timothy is your
coffee ever going to be available for
order up here in Kami Canada I need a
damn fine cup of Roberto Jr uh I I don't
know I guess we'll have to figure it out
international shipping we got to figure
that one out but the answer is it will
eventually we're hoping that in 10 years
it's a big brand it exists everywhere
for that matter I want to give Mr Beast
a shout out that dude's amazing oh I
love him he's got candy bars he's got
cheeseburgers feastables feastables is
his candy company so check us out Mr
Beast is doing everything and I think
that's fantastic uh his candy bars have
five ingredients
I was at 7-Eleven I see this because I'm
like I look at it and it's like
cream it's like milk cocoa sugar and
there's like no garbage in it I thought
it was great they melt really easily
though but that's that's very
inspirational to me I'm I'm how old is
Mr Beast like 26. I got like a decade on
this guy but he's he's hitting down on
that with the hammer he's got his show
and so what does he do he's expanding
all of his business in a bunch of
different areas and I think he's doing
good things cheeseburgers are fantastic
not the healthiest thing in the world
but the fact that he's making candy bars
that actually get rid of a lot of the
gunk in the garbage I think is a
positive step forward so I got mad
respect he's actually 25. 25. I got 12
years he got invited onto the Titans
submersible yeah glad he didn't turn it
down yeah yeah I mean uh uh you know if
candy bars are not good but if we can
replace the garbage plastic candy bars
with basic ingredients candy bars
because if people like Mr Beast we're
moving in a positive a little bit of him
is okay but the addictive quality of
sugar is what's really the the challenge
once you eat one piece you've got to
kind of set it down and and not let it
over overcome it's true dude it's dude
we have wine wineberry season has begun
and it's like nature Sour Patch Kids
when when you get them when they're
perfectly ripe and big and red and juicy
it's more like a Swedish Fish they don't
actually taste like it but if you get
them just before they read there's a
little sour tart to it and it is so good
and there's like 50 000 of them right
behind this window right here it's
amazing Tim Tim picked some and he's
like hey here why don't you try one of
these and then I like started eating it
I was like wait have you had one of
these you're like no I was like wait is
it gonna tell me that was scary I think
okay
that's right dude we made wineberry ice
cream we took an ice cream machine and
then we took the wine berries and we
just threw them in and the most amazing
thing happens it breaks the wine berries
up but doesn't pop the what are they
called druplets oh the little little
pods they freeze and so when you eat the
ice cream you have little Frozen
druplets that basically pop it's amazing
it's so good delicious yeah we're gonna
make um let's do that again we're gonna
make wine wine we're gonna make we may
jam with it plus we got mulberries bomb
alert I can't have mulberries we have
Allegheny and Himalayan Blackberry
everywhere
nature is great
yeah we want to do uh we want to make uh
oh and we got you can you can tap black
walnut trees for syrup really wow yeah
and they say tastes like butterscotch so
we're gonna make a black walnut syrup
because we got big black walnut trees
everywhere here black walnut oil I think
is like a a good medicine for uh super
excited for uh like anti-parasite
medicine it's used in parasite cleanses
yeah apparently the black walnut nut is
actually anti-parasitic I don't know
enough about that to get anywhere near
that apparently you can't eat them but I
read that you so there's Farms out here
that actually sell it's thick dark but
uh um uh black walnut syrup and it's
like it's like syrup you can put it on
pancakes it's like butterscotch and so
we're gonna we're gonna make some we're
gonna tap the tree and it takes a long
time and you gotta filter it boil it
down filter it again boil it down filter
it very excited plus we do have some
Maples we're thinking of tapping it's a
maple syrup too
super cool stuff yo it's crazy you walk
outside and I have this app called
picture this and we can see all the
different edible fruits and stuff yo the
grapes are everywhere from a distance
you like you like aim it and it tells
the picture yeah you take a picture and
it's like this is the plan there there's
an insane amount of grapes The Vines
have taken over everything wow yeah nuts
when you're like driving into the
property you can probably see like seven
thousand grapes yeah you can yeah
they're getting bigger lots of grates
out there grapes sorry yep
all right let's grab some more Super
chats
what have we here
mahil said four did a 2024 Ranger with
the militant Pride flag as a paint job
there you go
all right let's see Max redicks as I
heard you mentioned in a previous
segment that maybe you will invite Sam
on the culture War podcast I think how
Emma looked after her segment really
showed who she is you should consider
doing the same with Sam
the the I think I think we won't and the
reason is
when you know we what ended up was like
we something came up where we ended up
talking about the majority report
and then Emma vigiland hit us up saying
she wanted to come on the show because
they know that we're basically like we
invited salmon before he played us and
used it for drama on clickbait so I said
no more not doing it she came on the
show and we offered her a tour of the
property we offered her Sushi she stood
in the center of our skate park and met
some of our staff and then afterwards
she lied and claimed she didn't see the
skate park we didn't show her around and
it was the weirdest thing ever it's
because they're just lying to get clicks
they're apparently upset now because we
ran a segment that says leftist defends
you know uh adult Adult Book and and
dating apps for kids and they're angry
but she literally she literally said it
was a good book I was actually shocked
right because I I I've seen a bit of of
her content on the majority report I
responded to one of the videos they did
but for her to come say something was a
good book without knowing what was in it
I opened genderqueer and showed her and
she goes I don't care about that and I
don't believe in censors I'm sorry I'm
not trying to re-ash that yeah trying to
make a point just about Sam
the reason why I don't want him on this
show is because
what do we like to do serious
conversation around these issues and our
passions what will Sam do he'll come in
here and he'll like jump from the
rafters and body slam the table and do
others but we could talk about
socialized medicine and why like people
taking over risk kind of violates the
dose of social medicine he'll pretend to
misunderstand something to make you say
something to make a clip out of it yeah
I think that's what they do and then
he'll lie about what happened when he
came here like Emma did I think I have a
bulletproof defense on socialized
medicine and anyone who thinks that is
crazy in my opinion at first when Emma
said she didn't see the skatepark I'm
like did she not realize she was
standing next to us she maybe she walked
past and didn't realize there's ramps
everywhere and rails and a seven foot
tall vert wall and then I was told by
the staff that she actually stood in the
center of it after they parked their car
and she walked through it and it's like
okay so she's just lying that's if we
invite Sam on the show if you invite Sam
on your show that's what he does when I
invited him on Twitter he he lied and
said yes I'll come on the show and then
DM me privately saying I'm not going on
your show it was a trick it was a it's
it's just
let him you know what by all means Sam
do your thing if you're just making
reality TV make reality TV under the
guise of politics I'm down I'm not
whatever I just can't stand talking
about them I I would love to either
never mention the majority report Sam
Cedar Emma viglin never mention them
again and keep doing what we're doing or
have them on get over it and then never
mention them again we're talking about
them because we just had him on I'm on
last week and now they're lying about
what happened four clicks so it's it's
become something we'll talk about what
we talk about in three days probably not
uh this weekend I was wrong I said we're
gonna have two guests on this Friday
yeah next week that's next week yeah
this week we will have a good show as
well that I think will probably end
probably talking about abortion or
something so we'll see should be
interesting that next week is like
stacked
not this right but the next yes the next
one pardon me yeah that's gonna be a
blast it's a lot yeah very exciting we
should uh I'll reach out to our guests
to talk about like promotion for the
shows because we'll make like graphics
for it and everything yeah and then if
they're cool they probably are I just
don't like to say things before because
like I'll give them a heads up although
they may have talked about it already I
like the graphic for the Emma vigland
episode that you guys did I was kind of
fading and there's like Graphics in the
background it's really cool
I don't know
let's grab some more Super chats Daniel
doma6 has greatest side Hustle by Bud
Light for 12 bucks get 50 rebate and
make content destroying Bud Light double
dip monetize on both well I think the
rebates up to the purchase price so
actually the hustle would be to buy Bud
Light get the rebate and then you know
walk around with a cooler at baseball
games or something which you should not
do because you can't sell alcohol I'm
saying that would be a hustle I'll also
add this
the reason they're giving the rebates is
because they want you to take the
product because it's worse for them if
you don't so you have to pay to get rid
of it exactly Bud Light is in more pain
when you don't take their product
because they have to pay to get rid of
it that's why they're doing this do not
take the rebate don't try to do any kind
of hustle do nothing with this all right
they need to feel the pain this is
interesting Sam Samurai says we need a
strictly enforced tiered internet with
ratings like movies and TV shows we must
have this discussion in Congress and
pull up actual porn for Congressional
Record in seconds for America's deceit
it's interesting because in the early
days of the internet we are all very
much 100 pro Free Speech you should be
allowed to post whatever you want online
then we saw that people were posting and
we're like you know maybe this free
speech thing listen oh let's crack that
hold on
there are limits to what you're allowed
to do in public of course and so right
now we have the worst of Both Worlds you
are allowed to go in public with
pictures of aborted fetuses and protest
against abortion you are not allowed to
do that on the internet they will they
will delete your content they'll ban it
they'll say it's graphic and offensive
so the internet is allowing the worst
porn and stuff censoring political
debate it's the worst of everything you
cannot go into public and show lewd and
lascivious activities of adults
you will get charged for you know
breaking the like it's it's that's not
free speech unless you're a teacher for
whatever reason then well but right but
I mean like you're not gonna get in any
trouble talking about what we should be
allowed to do on the internet versus the
real world I think it should be
comparable you can't go into in Times
Square holding a big picture or holding
up a TV that's playing porn they will
immediately come and be like turn take
this down you can't do this it's illegal
but you can do it on the internet you
can do it on Twitter
if kids can have access to it we should
seriously question whether or not should
be allowed
at the same time you can go into Times
Square with pictures of aborted babies
and protest abortion they'd get mad at
you about it but that is free speech
that's protective based and P but people
do it yeah in a lot of places and so but
if you go on Twitter and do that they'll
flag you they'll censor the video and
say it's it's inappropriate I mean also
like if I I think this may have changed
under musk but if you just misgendered
somebody on Twitter like if you don't
use someone's fake made up pronouns that
that could get you kicked off Twitter in
real life you could do that so we need
to make sure our kids don't have access
to obscene content it should be a crime
to be sharing it with kids or let me put
it this way right now you have these
porn websites that are like are you
actually 18 you click yes like that's
ridiculous imagine if a guy was outside
in the street and he had a bunch of
nudie mags and a kid walked up and he
was like are you old enough like I said
yep works for me imagine if there was a
casino and a 10 year old kid walks in
and security guard goes are you old
enough to gamble the kid goes yeah
because works for me that's what I just
went to a b in Bev's website to find out
if Stella was one of their products and
was like hey wait before you view our
website are are you a team enter your
birthday I was like yes and they're like
okay good uh
yes a 10 year old kid who walks into a
bar like hey hold on there a minute are
you old enough to drink yes works for me
that's not how it works there was
there's a classic bit from the first
episode of The Simpsons where Bart sits
down he goes to get a tattoo and the guy
goes wait a minute are you 21 he's of
course certain he's like all right so
weird conversation because the
internet's not public it's not the
public like we know the public before
the internet like it's you do it from
your own home if you're sending an email
to someone there's no public activity
going on if it's a website that everyone
can access technically we consider it
kind of public but if someone doesn't
have a computer they have no ability to
access it so it's not really publicly
available unless you have money to buy a
machine no no that that's like saying it
if someone stands in Times Square with
with a picture it's not public
accessible because you can't travel the
Times Square everyone can travel to
Times Square everyone can walk there no
they can't yeah everyone has access foot
traffic no not everyone can get there
there's no like that's not true
Financial if you're if you're in Seattle
you're not going to survive a trek but
you could you could do it legally and
physically you physically could could
take a bus and go there and walk there
and be there without having to
well technically you'd have to buy the
bus ticket I guess in that position
right I'm saying like if you just walked
you you would have the resources to do
it but if you can make the argument you
can go to a library because the
computers are there for public use or
you can see the images on a TV in in a
in a bookstore uh display window so like
it's it is publicly accessible just
because you don't have the means to do
it it's not it's not publicly accessible
public I guess I want to mention
something Tim you mentioned there needs
to be stronger age verification on uh
pornographic websites aside from someone
just going yes I am 18. in Utah they
implemented a law requiring strengthened
protection so that children can stumble
on porn uh and what PornHub did was they
boycotted Utah as a result I said nope
we don't want to show stuff to people in
Utah it's like well that's a win on both
fronts but also you are making it
abundantly clear that it is extremely
important for your business model to be
able to show pornographic content to
minors I want to mention some things you
mentioned the 21 someone asked you for
21. we went out to eat like a couple
like a couple months ago and we're
ordering drinks and the waiter was like
are you 21 and I was like no
I'm 37. what what am I supposed to say
to that question are you 21 no I'm not
I'm older than that that's what I said I
was like no I'm older than 21. like it's
like a weird question at least 21.
exactly are you 21 no he's like wait
what I think a better formulation would
be have you 21 years because of 37 years
you do have 27. that's actually how they
phrase it I think in like French pianist
yeah yeah like how many years do you
think oh yeah and then like do you have
anything do you have 21 years I do I
have more than actually I do yeah are
you 21 no
all right John John Stewart says when I
had sex ed in high school in the 90s it
was about contraception use and STD
prevention and we had to have signed
parental consent yeah that's what I mean
they didn't give you BDSM education and
talk about eating poop they did talk
about I guess those were the Dark Ages
Tim even in fifth grade they told me it
was like 1988 or nine or something they
said like it is pleasurable and
abstinence they have accepted abstinence
doesn't work is a thing like they
weren't saying don't do it they were
saying if you do it be very careful use
a condom and they were like because STDs
and pregnancy that was like this is the
idea that abstinence doesn't work comes
from Kinsey and all that data was fudged
and yeah well that was a funny thing too
about when we had Emma on because she
asked me two things that didn't apply to
this show or me
she asked me if like well what if should
they allow the Bible in schools like
isn't the Bible I was like no I think
there's things in the in the Bible that
parents should probably be talking to
their kids about like uh uh what is it
um Ezekiel 23 20. the the meme uh verse
talks about emissions of horses and
stuff like that yeah that's like
something the parents probably so so
sure and then she asked me if I was in
favor of abstinence only sex education I
was like no of course not it's like oh
like dude like what do you think yeah
but uh let's uh what was I gonna read
oh here we go Thomas tjg says Reuters
claims that every living president are
descendants of slave owners except Trump
wait a minute wait I was admitted
they're all descendants well his mother
was white so maybe her ancestors were
trumps it's because I think Trump's uh
uh didn't Trump's grandparents immigrate
here yeah they were from Germany yeah
it's funny that they said that about
Obama too I just threw him in there it's
great does that hold on
I want to look that up I want to see if
it's true that Obama's grandparents I
was I saw this article early
grandparents yep no way yo but that's
that's that's that's not shocking for
the United States right like people you
need to realize what that means it means
that slave owners were raping slaves
like it's that's screwed up yeah and so
there are a lot of people in this
country who are black quarter tons of
slave motors for for very massive
reasons often when I explain to people
why you know my whole life I was told I
was Korean and then you know found out
that I was part Japanese it's not for
good reasons that my Korean ancestors
have some Japanese in them you know what
I mean like well I I is is that why they
talk about it because I would imagine if
you're if that was in your ancestry
because of a a slave being you know
abused by an owner that you wouldn't
like consider yourself a descendant of
them no you still are I'm just saying
there was that there was that um black
activist woman I forgot Rachel dolezal
no no she wasn't really black no there
was like a prominent uh black activist
who found out that she was the
descendant of who was that I don't
remember her name but remember the clip
yeah and everyone started laughing about
how funny it was and I'm like guys
that's not funny like that proves her
point that proves her activism that's a
good point dude they were trying to make
it seem like because she was Against
Racism and like fighting all this stuff
it was somehow discredited because she
was actually a descendant of slave
owners and I'm like no that bolsters all
of her arguments
be like yeah you're against this thing
then why did your ancestors do it what
excuse me
yeah I'm like I tell people like oh yeah
for most of my life I said I was like
you know Park Korean but now I know that
I'm five percent Japanese and they're
like oh that's cool I'm like actually
it's not like it's kind of actually it's
not no it kind of is I don't know but
it's like kind of horrifying when you
think about it
yeah not a lot not a lot of good things
were happening over there and a long
time ago if you get my drift all right
let's see we got gs059 says Ian people
demanded gun free zones now there are
signs everywhere it doesn't matter if
they work or not that's a good point
they were like hey we don't want guns
here so put up a sign and then people
are just criminals just gonna criminal
yeah doesn't matter I'm gonna stop them
powder PC says why aren't we talking
about the actual content of the audio
tape not just that one line they were
trying to force him to evade Iran yeah I
know like he was like look Millie Drew
up these documents to invade everyone
that's why they're going after him
partly because Trump was like we're not
going to invade this are you nuts and
they were like we want to and you're
gonna do it Trump didn't start any new
Wars that's why they don't like him
partly why they don't like him it's a
big reason oh this okay I'm totally
sidetracking here but I just realized
when you mentioned the thing about Obama
potentially being the descendant of uh
people who own slaves but but Obama's
not a descendant of slaves like his his
dad was from Kenya yes he's not the
descendant of American slaves yep
um so if if he does have right slave
holders in his past that it would have
been like it wouldn't have been because
I still don't think it matters to be
completely honest like look
I don't want to punish people for the
sins of their ancestors but at the same
time you know you can imagine that being
used against any Republican Thomas
Jefferson known slaves he had a lot of
really really awesome ideas owning
slaves is not one of the good things he
did yeah however the the ideas and the
seeds that were planted by the founding
fathers LED very quickly to the
abolition of slavery look people point
out that the um the commonwealth
countries abolished slavery well before
we did
and it's true uh and then we had to
fight a massive Civil War partially over
slavery over the issues around it
economics it's more a lot more
complicated than that and a lot of
people died because of it and you know
so
I think the founding documents and the
founding fathers for all their faults
planted some some good seeds well what
would have made this country fantastic I
would agree and people will argue well
the founders wanted the United States to
be this new free country but then they
didn't put anything in the Constitution
that forbid slavery okay we're not going
to get the 13 colonies to ratify the
Constitution and the Bill of Rights if
you had something in there that banned
slavery it doesn't mean that all of the
founders were in favor of slavery it it
just means that as a political reality
they were not going to be able to have
their system of government Pass unless
the colonies ratified and if they
couldn't get it to pass then they would
just go back to England which was not
based on principles of freedom and so
there would be less reason to believe
slavery whatever and the power that
Thomas Jefferson had was a lot of it was
because of the slaves that that he owned
uh doing his labor for him and without
that power he wouldn't have been as
influential and able to go to Congress
and be a congressman and all those
things so it was you know it's
double-edged sword
the cranky genexor says wait I don't
know what that means
I'm not gonna read that one Dave Dowell
says Ian Cali has border checks for
produce they check random cars not just
Farmers if a state wants checkpoints
it's legal also the whole point of
defunding the police is to create a
National Police
yeah um many many people pointing out
that there are checkpoints for fruit
laws yes California and Nevada yes crazy
yeah actually I think wine berries are a
legal transport interesting because of
the bugs no because they're an invasive
species they choke out other plants yeah
but they're so good they are massive and
they're raspberries they're they're a
Chinese kind of raspberry and they're
called wine berries because people make
wine with them and uh we in we intend to
harvest them and we're going to juice
them we're gonna make we're gonna make a
syrup with the wineberry juice we're
gonna like cook it down maybe a little
lemon juice and some sugar and then
we're going to use the pulp to make
cakes and cookies
yeah it's gonna be awesome and we're
gonna make ice cream to be honest so
great we're gonna make ice cream
machines really fun you like scrape it
it's getting cold on the top we have two
we have the one that automatically spins
and then we have the the cold sheet
where you you pour it on and then you
scrape it and mix it around yeah it's so
much fun
yeah you can buy them on Amazon good fun
stuff
all right let's see what we got in the
old Super Chat sea
Ian Kenny says did you reach out to Ice
Cube for the culture war or IRL I think
somebody did I don't handle booking so
he's going on a tour
he is well not a musical tour he's going
on a tour to talk about how he can't
stand them I don't know what he's a
global economic order I'm not sure he's
he's frustrated about something he wants
to let people know the gatekeeper Ice
Cube yeah
Ice Cube says
he's going to bypass The Gatekeepers and
do shows and stuff all right Brynn Terra
Nova says is trash house taking demo
submissions I don't know so uh salt
stations are very very hard I think
we'll have to confer with Carter on how
we want to handle that moving forward
and then he's basically in charge of it
also
but uh I will talk to him about it we
have a new song coming out shortly and
we're in we're negotiating with another
band about releasing some songs that I
think are absolutely fantastic so we'll
see what happens
and then yeah we want we want more
absolutely
let's grab a couple more here
is Monster says I can't believe I really
heard Sheamus say societies survived
because of the Ten Commandments let's
just ignore all those other
civilizations that existed before
Christianity killed everyone else hold
on no no no that that's completely
ridiculous uh people had something
approximating the Ten Commandments in
very many cultures throughout world
history and if if your culture ended up
rising to a point of prominence we were
able to amass wealth and have a
large-scale civilization it's because
you were following something
approximating The Ten Commandments dude
you cannot have a functioning society
and you cannot build wealth if if one
person is sleeping with every woman in
the community people are committing
adultery people are stealing people are
killing what's happened in various
societies historically is as they become
wealthy and as they've become insulated
certain people who are very high status
ended up being able to routinely violate
those moral principles without suffering
consequences and there wasn't the same
Christian framework to tell them that
even as powerful people there would be
Eternal consequences for their actions
but people at the bottom of the
hierarchy and people who were living in
a state of nature basically always came
to the same moral conclusions and if
they didn't come to those moral
conclusions their tribe never rose out
of its more
um natural state to build a large-scale
civilization with X is all I'm thinking
about they weren't really large scale I
guess yeah well no no so but but even
the Aztecs right the the Aztecs had a
horrific culture and and I acknowledged
that there have been many horrible and
satanic cultures throughout history but
the the masses were not encouraged to do
things like steel kill and rape and if
they were then those civilizations
crumbled and let's talk about that in
the members only show so smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member because the uncensored members
only show will begin in a few minutes
and you don't want to miss it it's going
to be a good fun you can follow the show
at timcastirl you can follow me
personally at timcast Gene do you want
to shout anything out hey just uh thanks
for having me on I go to our website
aflegal.org check it out check out all
the work that we're doing censorship
parents rights everything fighting the
culture wars for everybody
I make cartoons uh I have a YouTube
channel called Freedom tunes and a
website called freedomtunes.com We're
releasing a video this Thursday about
the pride month that wasn't I think you
guys are going to enjoy it and I think
you'll also enjoy the video we released
last week where I reviewed a bunch of
pride month memes I fixed them I
actually made them funny it's a 10
minute long video I think you'll like it
and there's a 30 minute long cut of it
behind the paywall head over there check
it out thank you so much and have a
wonderful day have an extremely awesome
evening and day tomorrow as well have a
great week I'm Ian Crossland very happy
to see you guys happy to be a part of
the show Good to be here Gene people are
going to follow you on Twitter it's at
America First legal that's though it's a
one America one St legal you got it hell
yeah dude good to see you again man
likewise Serge take me out yeah I am
search.com I'll be in the comments this
evening because uh I feel like seeing
what you guys have to say
um follow me on Twitter at surge.com
spell it out let's do it we will see you
all over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out